ja und wie angekündigt jetzt die Rede
des CSU Parteivorsitzenden Markus Söder
zum politischen Aschermittwoch in Passau
diesen Gruß würde in Berlin niemand
machen aber wir machen ihn wir sagen
ganz bewusst grüß Gott hier zu allen in
der Halle grüß Gott zu allen Zuschauern
in Bayern und der ganzen Welt liebe
Freundinnen Freunde wir sind wieder da
hier in Passau holzte so
wie habe ich das wie habe ich euch
vermisst wir sind wieder hier in unserem
Revier liebe Freundinnen Freunde das ist
das Wohnzimmer der CSU und für jeden
Parteivorsitzenden ist es die größte
Aufgabe des Jahres mit seiner Partei und
vielen Bürgerinnen hier zusammenzukommen
es stimmt schon die anderen versuchen
seit Jahren
Passau nachzumachen bei den Grünen
sitzen weniger Gäste als bei uns Ordner
sind und auch die anderen liebe Freunde
wollen so sein wie wir aber das schafft
keiner wir sind die stärksten wer sind
die besten wir sind im Wasser
das schöne ist für mich ich muss heute
nicht nur als Ministerpräsident sondern
ich darf als Parteivorsitzender reden
und da ist Klartexter bei anderen gibt
es Klamauk bei anderen gibt es Chichi
bei uns gibt es rhetorisch deftige
Hausmannskost und man kann es so sagen
die Politiker Korrektness hat endlich
Pause weil wir am Ende hier in Passau
das sagen was wir denken und Frauen das
zu sagen was die Menschen fühlen wir
haben keine Schere im Kopf sondern wir
sprechen aus Herz und Leidenschaft das
ist pass auf pur liebe Freunde
und dieses Jahr passt der Aschermittwoch
perfekt der Countdown läuft am 8 Oktober
ist landtags- und bezirkstagswahl das
wird ein Marathon mit volldampflebe vor
einem Freunde die Ausgangslage ist
besser als 20 18 und viel besser als
nach der Bundestagswahl sind wir bitte
ehrlich nach der Bundestagswahl 2021 da
waren wir schon in einer Zelle in einer
Depression und die Opposition klopfte
sich auf die Schenkel und hatte
Hoffnungen heute zu Beginn des Jahres
2023 ist es genau andersrum die csus dem
Aufwärtstrend und die Opposition die
verunsichert die Umfragen sind wieder
stabil die Tendenz geht nach oben wir
sind wieder nah bei den Menschen jetzt
sind wieder nah bei den Leuten wir sind
in der Mitte von Bayern wir haben uns
nach einem harten Jahr wieder nach oben
gekämpft wir sind vorne wir sind
gekommen um zu bleiben wir wollen die
Landtagswahlen im Herbst gewinnen liebe
Freunde und zwar zusammen
und es war kein leichter Weg
denn es findet alles unter
außergewöhnlichen und das schweren
Bedingungen statt Pandemie Ukraine
wir sind jetzt im Jahr zwei der
ampelzeitrechnung
das erste Jahr waren das darf man
wirklich sagen ohne jemanden zu treten
chaotisch
es ist kein Vorwurf wenn man schwere
Entscheidungen zu treffen hat aber wenn
man falsche macht muss man das Benennen
das ampelprinzip ist seit über einem
Jahr spät entscheiden hin und her
entscheiden handwerkliche Fehler machen
und sich dabei zerstreiten ich glaube
man kann sagen die neue Bundesregierung
die Ampel ist die schlechteste
Bundesregierung die Deutschland je hatte
Liebe Freund Freunde
das peinlichste ampelkapitel Kapitel war
bislang das Thema Verteidigungspolitik
wir hatten so große Hoffnung Liebe
Alexander Dobrindt nach der Rede des
Bundeskanzlers und es war bislang eine
so große Enttäuschung
alle reden von Zeiten Wände aber es ist
bislang nur eine Zeitlupe
viele Ankündigungen und die Wahrheit das
einzige was bislang wirklich zustande
gekommen ist waren 5000 Helme liebe
Freundinnen Freunde sonst nichts nichts
bestellt nichts gekauft nichts gemacht
mittlerweile werden von den 100
Milliarden er Großteil durch die
Inflation aufgefressen und kann gar
nichts gehen und der Grund war eine
spd-ministerin die länger am Amt lebte
als manche am Boden liebe Freundinnen
und Freunde ja
diese Ministerin Frau Lamprecht den
Namen müssen sich nicht mehr merken
aber diese Ministerin war eine Blamage
für Deutschland es war ein Fehler vom
Bundeskanzler so lang an ihr
festzuhalten und das einzig gute an Frau
Lamprecht ist dass sie endlich weg ist
liebe Freunde und Freunde das einzige
wir wünschen übrigens den neuen
Verteidigungsminister alles alles Gute
und wir unterstützen auch die Politik
gerade weiß ich der Jahrestag näher der
Ukraine zu helfen wir stehen zur Ukraine
und wir wollen auch das Russland diesen
Krieg nicht gewinnt sondern dass die
Ukraine erfolgreich ist und ich sage
auch danke weil ich den amerikanischen
generalkonsor sehe es ist einfach wieder
ein gutes Gefühl wenn wir Amerika
Deutschland und besonders Amerika und
Bayern wieder zusammenstehen danke für
eure Engagement wir sind da gemeinsam
aber wisst ihr
wir helfen wir helfen auch mit Waffen
aber irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl dass
ein Teil in dieser Ampel im Moment
völlig überdreht und zwar die Grünen
früher waren sie Ostern jetzt sind sie
militärmarschieren
wenn die Grünen früher früher von Leos
und Leoparden geredet haben dann redeten
sie meist vom Artenschutz liebe Freunde
jetzt jetzt hat man den Eindruck die
Grünen reden sich gerade zu in einen
kriegsrausch besonders Frau bärbock sie
sagte vor einem der wichtigsten Gremien
Manfred ist es gibt in Europa den
Europarat Deutschlands Achtung
Deutschlands sei im Krieg mit Russland
ich will mal eines sagen
vielleicht darf man den Passau des ein
oder andere überzeichnen was wir in der
Regel nicht tun ja
wir sind sehr sanft und empathisch hier
sieht es an den Gesichtern
aber eine Außenministerin muss aufpassen
was sie sagt die Eskalation von Sprache
kann schnell zur Eskalation von Gewalt
führen und deswegen will ich sagen wir
helfen in der Ukraine aber Deutschland
ist nicht im Krieg mit Russland das kann
nicht gehen herr Scholz stoppen sie
endlich Frau bärburg mit ihren
unbedachten Äußerungen zum Schaden
unseres Landes
bin freundlich zu ihr aber ich muss sie
fragen was soll eigentlich diese
feministische Außenpolitik liebe Freunde
das wird wie ein riesiger Irrweg
man hat den Eindruck es wird nicht
Diplomatie Betrieben im Außenministerium
sondern Mission das bisherige Ergebnis
war dass man Kreuze entfernt
Seele umbenennt und statt kundige
Diplomaten mittlerweile NGO Aktivisten
in die Regierung holt wir entwickeln uns
unsere Ampel zur eine ngo-republik und
die Außenpolitik der Grünen ist eine
neuer grüner Wilhelminismus nach dem
Motto am grünen Wesen soll die Welt
genießen eines sage ich euch schon so
werden wir auf Dauer zum einsamen Mann
oder wie Frau bärbock sagen würde zur
einsamen Frau in Europa wir wollen das
nicht die Grünen sind ein
Sicherheitsrisiko für unser Land liebe
Freunde
wir stehen zur Hilfe
Bayern ist ein herzliches Land wir
helfen wir helfen gerne wir haben mehr
Menschen aus der Ukraine aufgenommen als
beispielsweise Frankreich ich danke
unseren Kommunalpolitikern lieber
Landrat Kneidinger und vielen anderen
herzlich dafür für die Aufnahme für
alles was getan wird um zu helfen
aber wir spüren gerade dass das alles an
seine Grenzen stößt an die Grenzen der
Machbarkeit ich danke den Kommunen noch
einmal aber wenn selbst grüne Landräte
in Bayern was zum Glück nur eingibt ja
zum Glück ja wenn der sagt wir bräuchten
mal ein bisschen Zeit zum Durchschnaufen
aber übrigens gleich von seinen eigenen
grünen wieder zum Rücktritt aufgefordert
die alten Reflexe funktionieren noch
fakt ist unsere Hilfe
steht vor der Herausforderung fakt ist
der Zugang in diesem Jahr lieber Joachim
letzten Jahr war stärker als
2015/2016 und deswegen sagen wir an der
Ampel auch die adressiert sie muss
auffangen es ist nicht davor von
Menschen die Schutz suchen sie ist in
der Vorwurf einer Bundesregierung die
das ganze katastrophal organisiert liebe
Freunde und Freunde sie können es
einfach nicht und wenn sie dann einen
Gipfel machen und Kommunalvertreter
einladen und außer einen kalten Kaffee
und eine Brezel es nicht gibt dann ist
das einfach zu wenig wir erwarten vom
Bund dass er zwei Dinge tut auf der
einen Seite sage ich klar wir stehen zu
Hilfe wir stehen zum Migration für
Arbeit aber wir sagen nein zur
Überforderung der Kommunen und Nein zu
illegaler Zuwanderung nach Deutschland
liebe Freunde
und Frau Feser den Namen ich immer
irgendwie sympathisch finde weil als
altersstart-trainer erinnert mich das
immer an
Phaser wir wissen was sie meinen ja
Frau Feser muss nicht nur Wahlkampf in
Hessen machen
sondern sie muss für Deutschland ein Amt
ausfüllen wenn sie jetzt nicht bald
Vorschläge macht Joachim wie der Zugang
gesteuert und die Kommunen entlastet und
mehr Geld an der Stelle überwiesen wird
wir geben übrigens das bayerischer
Freistaat geben den Kommunen große
Unterstützung ganz bewusst wenn sie das
nicht so drauf Frau Feser dann wird sie
die nächste Frau Lamprecht in Kabinett
von Scholz und es würde auch den Kanzler
gut anstehen wenn er sich endlich selber
um diese Probleme in Deutschland kümmert
und nicht nur durch die Weltreise liebe
Freunde wir haben hier die Probleme und
eine Regierung muss hier agieren und
musste
[Applaus]
weil ich jetzt schon wieder weiß dass da
einer nicht Journalist die Augenbrauen
zuckt
wir sagen ja zu Integration
wir sagen ja zu Unterstützung aber wir
sagen nein auch zu einer Änderung des
ideologischen Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht
liebe Freunde habt ihr das mitbekommen
die neue Regierung will das
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht komplett
verändern
das Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft ist die
höchste Anerkennung eines Staates
es ist nicht wie die Mitgliedschaft in
einem Verein oder eine Yoga-Gruppe ja
wer die Staatsbürgerschaft will braucht
ein Bekenntnis zum Land ein Bekenntnis
zu den Werten und auch ein Bekenntnis
zur Sprache die neue Ampel will die
Sprache quasi völlig ausschalten ich
sage ich aber eines wir wollen keinen
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht leid wir wollen
einen wirkliche Anerkennung der
Staatsbürgerschaft und um die zu
bekommen muss man die Sprache sprechen
wer Deutscher werden will muss auch
Deutsch sprechen können liebe Freunde
und Freunde alles andere ist doch ein
Unsinn
und so nebenbei
wenn alle von Integration reden kann ich
nur empfehlen
keine Seminare in Berlin zu besuchen
sondern eine Reise nach Bayern zu machen
wir sind ein Vorbild für Integration
Liebe Joachim wir haben im letzten Jahr
mehr Zuzug als Norder
Nordrhein-Westfalen
dabei haben wir trotz des hohen Zuzuges
die niedrigste Kriminalitätsrate die
niedrigste Arbeitslosenquote und das
zeigt bei uns in Bayern klappt
Integrationen das liebe Freunde ist der
fundamentale Unterschied zwischen Bayern
und den linken andere reden von
Integration wir machen sie Bayern ist
der deutsche Meister der Integration und
deswegen brauchen wir keine altbackenen
linken Multikulti Belehrungen mehr wir
machen es auf unsere Weise und die
anderen sollen sich an Vorbild an Bayern
nehmen liebe Freunde
Landwirtschaft erfolgreich für
Deutschland
das ist übrigens kein ampelbashing
im Wesentlichen
das ist nur Sorge
Sorge um Deutschland und natürlich um
unser Land Bayern
ein weiteres sorgenpunkt war und ist das
Thema Energie
seit einem Jahr ging es hin und her
ist es Bayern bekommen überhaupt kein
Gas wir haben gekämpft und es ist
gekommen dann hieß es hier innen sich
noch habe die gasumlage soll kommen was
die Preise erhöht hätte wir haben
demonstriert sie viel dann hieß es eine
gaspreisbremse Alex kommt aber nur für
einen Monat wir haben kritisiert es ist
die ganze Zeit und bis heute ist es ein
Theater weil nicht genau geklärt ist ob
auch für Ölheizungen eine entsprechende
Unterstützung gibt da will ich nur eines
dazu sagen
in den Städten gibt es weniger Ölheizung
aber eine Bundesregierung oder eine
Mehrheit im Parlament die Ölheizungen
schlechter behandelt als Gas zeigt nur
eines sie haben kein Verständnis von den
ländlichen Räumen wir fordern Gleichheit
nicht nur der Gaskunde braucht den
lastung sondern auch der deine Ölheizung
hat und Pellets benutzt liebe Freunde
was an der Energiepolitik der Ampel
nervt ist auch hier wieder zu spät
halbherzig und auch Ideologie
am Anfang fand ich das noch alles ganz
witzig
Frage woran erkennt man grüne
an ihren waschgewohnheiten liebe Freunde
da habe ich
duschsterne kalt tolle Idee im Winter
der von mir hochgeschätzte Winfried
Kretschmann habe mir während einer
ministerpräsentkonferenz wir sitzen
nebeneinander mögen uns wirklich mit
seinem Waschlappen erklärt wo an welchen
Stellen man
ich kämpfe bis heute jede Nacht darum
die Bilder aus dem Kopf zu bekommen
und eine der super
Senatorin in der grünen aus Berlin sagt
er waschensalbe völlig beschäftigt das
könnte man sein lassen
stellt euch mal vor wie hätten uns seit
November nicht mehr gewaschen liebe
Freunde ja es wäre dann hier ein
besonderes Aroma und wenn wir aufstehen
kleben wir die Bänke mit
ein Quatsch nach dem anderen aber da
könnte man doch lachen wie wir es tun
aber schlimmer ist diese
Durchdringung mit Ideologie beim Thema
Kernkraft
die Entscheidungen zu kennen Energie in
Deutschland sind ohne Logik und Verstand
gemacht Liebe
ohne Logik und Verstand
was für ein absurd ist Theater nur wegen
den Grünen
die Grünen faseln vom Klima und Baggern
aber lieber nach Kohle
sage ich euch jetzt voraus wird das war
das emotionale Wackersdorf der Grünen
wird
es ist doch sowas von unglaubwürdig und
peinlich wenn Deutschland Frankreich
bietet könntet ihr uns ein bisschen
Atomstrom geben wir wollen ihn nicht
ist es nicht peinlich und lächerlich
wenn man andere Länder wie die USA aber
auch Holland bitte Norwegen könntet ihr
uns ein bisschen von eurem Gas geben wir
trauen uns nicht selber zu bohren und
wird der liebe Freunde und Freunde dann
tatsächlich zu einer totalen
Tag nach Katar fährt vor der WM und
großspurig erklärt wie die Kataris sich
zu verändern haben hat er uns super
Effekt von unserer Mannschaft gehabt ja
und am nächsten Tag
ist der war alles sehr sehr alt und am
nächsten Tag liebevollen Freunde am
nächsten Tag
am nächsten Tag fährt man hin macht
einen Hofknicks und bettelt bei den
gleichen die man am Tag zuvor beleidigt
hat um Gas so gibt Deutschland in der
Welt ein peinliches Bild ab und daran
sind die Grünen Schuld liebe Freunde
Robert Habeck ist ein netter Mann
so ein bisschen knuffig und knuddelig
rüber ja bei denen ins Feld und wirkt
das so ein bisschen wie der Captain Iglo
von der Küste
aber eins sage ich euch
wenn wir ehrlich sind ein
Wirtschaftsminister der sich schwer tut
zu erkennen dass das auf die Aufgabe von
Produktion nicht zu einer Insolvenz
führen könnte den kann ich nur eines
sagen das ist das schlechteste
Wirtschaftsminister alle Zeiten Ludwig
Erhard würde in Grab rotieren wenn er
wüsste dass er einen solchen Nachfolger
hat tut mir leid
wir schimpfen aber nicht mehr
wir haben einen eigenen Plan entwickelt
für die Krise und zwar verlässlich von
Anfang an eine Linie entwickelt wir
haben härtefallfonds gemacht fast zwei
Milliarden lieber Albert für alle
Bereiche der Wirtschaft der Bürger
sozialen Einrichtungen Sportkultur
Vereine und wir setzen auch sehr auf den
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien weil
wir noch besser werden
kam plötzlich aber letztes Jahr so Mitte
des Jahres eine schlimme Befürchtung
haben
die Grünen behauptet Bayern sei Bayern
neuer fahren Energie in ganz am
Schlusslicht völlig verunsichert habe
den Wirtschafts- und Energieminister
Hubert albacher eingestellt Absatz
dann haben wir nachgeschaut und es ist
schon ein Hammer liebe Freunde und ein
Meister Beispiel für politische
Unwahrheit
ich würde meine eingehen lassen in
Bayern bei den Erneuerbaren wirklich
total schlecht werden dann wird man
sagen müssen wir halt nur besser werden
aber im letzten Jahr der Generalsekretär
hat es sehr schöner mehr aufgedröselt
und die Landesgruppe und der alexander
dobin hat das Bundestag eine Anfrage
gestellt und eine Antwort bekommen
danach sind wir da klar vorne wir sind
bei der Dynamik und beim Ausbau
erneuerbaren Energien im letzten Jahr
absolute Spitze
25% des deutschen Ausbaus sind in Bayern
gemacht worden mehr als
Nordrhein-Westfalen und
Baden-Württemberg zusammen wie man dann
ständig behaupten kann dass der dann der
Spitze steht da Abstiegskandidat war
kann kein Zufall sein und ich bezichtige
hier Meiniger Grünen die es immer wieder
behaupten schlichtweg der Lüge und ich
kann nur eines sagen wer in der
Regierung lügt hat keinen Anspruch
länger Regierungsmitglied zu sein liebe
Freunde es ist gang und gäbe
und obwohl wir gut liegen legen wir zu
weil ihr müssen mehr tun wir müssen noch
unabhängige von Russland werden Manfred
natürlich und wir haben übrigens auch
einen Zuwachs nach Bayern also brauchen
wir Energie deswegen haben wir noch
meine extra halbe Milliarde
freigeschaufelt für erneuerbare
energieprogramme
Photovoltaik das sind wir übrigens
stärker dass sie das mal gehört haben
stärker als Nordrhein-Westfalen
Baden-Württemberg und Rheinland-Pfalz
zusammen
übrigens für die künftige Metrologie
Wind nimmt in Deutschland ab habe ich
gelesen und Sonne zu bei Wasserkraft
erzeugen wir mehr erneuerbare Energien
als Rheinland-Pfalz und ja liebe
Freundin beim Vincent wir nicht ganz
vorne aber vor Baden-Württemberg
wir liegen auf Platz
interessant deswegen weil wenn selbst
grüne Regierungen beim Wind im Süden
nicht ganz so erfolgreich sind könnte
theoretisch könnte es vielleicht auch
damit zusammenhängen dass im Norden mehr
Wind weht und im Süden mehr die Sonne
ist man könnte es geographisch
zusammenfassen im Süden Scheins und im
Norden pfeift liebevollen feiern was die
Realität
aber wir machen da mehr
Michaela im Staatswald vielen anderen
Bereichen wir haben jetzt bereits
aufgrund der veränderten der farming
Christian fast 25% neuer Anträge aber
wisst ihr was jetzt schon wieder losgeht
reinscheiden uns wir wollen es machen
aber es gibt eine Gruppe die wieder
überall dagegen das sind übrigens nicht
wild gewordene CSU-Bürgermeister dieses
Fort behindern es sind meistens NGOs und
leider auch einige Umweltverbände die
gegen alles und überall klagen jetzt
muss ich mal ganz ehrlich sagen ein Teil
unseres Fortschritts wird behindert weil
Leute die nicht mal Anwohner sind gegen
bestimmte Dinge klagen können es ist
echt mal an der Zeit diese Verbandsklage
Rechte irgendwelche ngo-funktionäre
einzuschränken liebe Freunde müssen auch
Vorankommen in Deutschland könnte da
stehen bleiben
also wir sind bei Photovoltaik super bei
Wasser super bei Geothermie wir bauen
beim Wind aus und wir sind noch in einer
anderen Disziplin sensationell und jetzt
kommt hier gleichzeitig ein Vorwurf es
betrifft das Thema biomast
im letzten Jahr bei ein Drittel des
Zubaus aus Bayern wir haben mehr
Bioenergie aus Biomasse als ganz Hessen
ein riesiges Land
erneuerbare Energien hat
komischerweise das ist die Frage
komischerweise setzt die Bundesregierung
nur auf Wind sie behindert Wasser und
sie behindert Biomasse und warum wohl
weil sie zum einen den Süden nicht mag
und zum anderen die Landwirtschaft nicht
achtet liebe Freunde ich kann nur eines
sagen
vor einigen Wochen war die Grüne Woche
in Berlin seine Leistungsschau der land-
und Ernährungswirtschaft was
sensationell Bayern hat sich super
präsentiert alles sind zu uns gekommen
dieser logisch wir haben das beste Essen
der Welt liebe Freunde ja das beste
Essen der Welt
[Applaus]
also Grüne Woche ist auch toll das
einzige was mir eine Grünen Woche stört
ist der Name
aber sonst super der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister er ötzte
mir macht dann auch das ist positiv eine
ernährungskonferenz lädt alle
Landwirtschaftsminister der Welt ein um
zu sagen wie stoppen wir den Hunger der
Welt und eine zentrale Forderung ist
dass die starken westlichen Länder die
Industrieländer mehr Nahrungsmittel
produzieren so weit so gut Frage
produzieren wir in unserem Land alles
was wir können müssen wir eines sagen
wir haben in Deutschland ein solches
Management was Flächen betrifft dass wir
uns stilllegen von den Grünen die
oberste Direktive ist ja liebe Freunde
haben wir einen Zeitenwende oder nicht
wollen wir der Welt helfen ihre
Ernährungsprobleme zu lösen oder nicht
und wenn wir das wollen dann hört
endlich auf in Berlin Flächen
stillzulegen Flächen zu blockieren lass
die Landwirtschaft ihren Job machen die
können das am besten besser als grüne
Ideologen liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
sie wollen flächenstilllegen Michaela
und die Tierhaltung komplett reduzieren
50%
. man spürt eine richtige Fleisch und
Wurst verbieten Liebe
übrigens wir essen auch alle ganz Salat
wir essen auch gern Gemüse eine mehrere
weniger so
ich finde es auch völlig in Ordnung wenn
sich jemand vegetarisch und vegan
ernährt jeder soll es entscheiden aber
wenn ich höre dass in Münchner Kitas
entschieden wird weder Fleisch noch
Fisch da muss ehrlich sagen was tut man
den Kindern an stellt euch vor ein
Kindergeburtstag soll mit Brokkoli und
Karotten zum Erfolg geführt werden eine
völlig absurde Idee
und einige haben sogar Hass auf Fleisch
richtigen Hass die
Tierschutzorganisation Peter da gibt
sicherlich ein paar ganz tolle Leute
kennen zwar keine aber gibt's
die sagen wer Fleisch ist
dem sollte ein fortpflanzungsverbot
auferlegt werden
wisst ihr was ich das Absurde dabei
finde außer dass ich so viel Kinder habe
also wir können es recht sein ja
es wird über Hormone im Fleisch
debattiert
könnten zu viel Hormone sein
aber gleichzeitig will eine grüne
Ministerin Kindern Hormone verabreichen
um ihr geschlechtlich zu entwickeln
liebe Freunde die absurd ist es
eigentlich in unserem Land mittlerweile
geworden ist
und
das Besondere ist dabei man hat ja schon
einen Satz Essen gefunden jetzt heißt es
kein Fleisch aber Insekten
damit Kabinett diskutiert das heißt
jetzt nobel food immer Niederbayern
Erwin Huber sagt ja die hausgrille und
der
getreideschimmelkäfer sollen jetzt
essbar sein
es ist schon Wahnsinn ja vor drei Jahren
hieß es rettet die Bienen und jetzt
futtert die Käfer liebe Freunde oder ist
schon lustig oder
ich will es hier und wenn ihr damit
einverstanden habt als offizielle
Botschaft auch der bayerischen
Staatsregierung der CSU zusammenfassen
liebe Freunde wir essen wieder
Schweinsbraten statt Insekten oder Maden
Müsli und wenn ihr das wollt Liebe grüne
dann könnt ihr das Zeug selber fressen
wir haben das nicht niemals
ich will ein Bekenntnis abgeben für
unsere Landwirtschaft für unsere Bauern
Liebe Günter Felsner heidelein Vorgänger
sitzt mit da wir stehen dazu und seid
bitte ehrlich ihr habt uns auch oft
geschimpft und
vielleicht auch ab und zu ein bisschen
zurecht denn immer aber seid mal ehrlich
die FDP ist doch in der Regierung eine
totale Enttäuschung die Freien Wähler
reden viel aber tun sich schwer was
umzusetzen die AFD sinnlos und die
Grünen echte ideologische Feind die
einzigen auf die ihr euch wirklich
verlassen können und zwar nicht nur mit
Sonntagsreden sondern praktischen Arbeit
ist die CSU nicht verspreche euch wir
arbeiten daran einen neuen Partner der
Landwirtschaft zu machen denn wir wollen
nicht die Norddeutschen Agrarfabriken
wir wollen unseren Erhalt der feierlich
bäuerlichen Betriebe liebe liebe Freunde
lieber Familienbetrieb als ein
agrar-aktie
und wenn ich schon bei Landwirtschaft
bin kürzer Einschub zum ländlichen Raum
bis heute
glauben die ampelparteien auch in Bayern
die kleine SPD
die noch kleinere FDP und vor allem die
Grünen glauben dass der ländliche Raum
liebevollen Freunde eigentlich eher so
eine Art
Naturschutzgebiet eher so eine Art
Museum ist sie haben nicht verstanden
dass der ländliche Raum die Seele
Bayerns ist wir werden diese Seele
erhalten liebe Freunde und Freunde für
uns ist der ländliche Raum zukunftsraum
und nicht nur urlaubsausfahrt für einige
müde Großstädter liebe Freunde wir
stehen dazu
deswegen
christian hat es gesagt
auch der ÖPNV ist ganz besonders wichtig
bis zu einer landkreispräsident
Karmas in der Nachfolger schönes Leben
im Präsidentenstuhl ist das schöner Job
wir setzen im Haushalt albert führerke
hat sich erweichen lassen wir setzen im
Haushalt so hoch wie nie den ÖPNV an
Baden-Württemberg übrigens nimmt
Maßnahmen zurück ne wir setzen drauf
klimapusse ein Ticket 49 und 29 Euro
Schienenverbindung Radwege Rad gesetzt
aber jetzt kommt der entscheidende Punkt
es tun wir alles
aber wir sind nicht gegen das Auto liebe
Freunde
wir sind nicht gegen das Auto
man kann im ländlichen Raum ohne das
Auto auch schwer seine Mobilität
erhalten übrigens echte autofeinde sind
die Grünen was wir für ein Theater jedes
Jahr haben mit der IAA Internationalen
Automobilausstellung München man spürt
geradezu die Abneigung aber ich will es
hier mal deutlich machen wir stehen dazu
wir sagen ja zum Straßenbau wir sagen ja
zur Ansiedlung von BMW-Werk wir sagen ja
zum synthetischen Verbrenner und uns
fällt aus dass die FDP in fünf behaupten
nichts durchsetzt wir sind das kann man
sagen und bleiben es auch Bayern ist
Autoland und die CSU bleibt die einzige
echte autoparteil Liebe Freunde und dazu
stehen auch wir brauchen es auch davon
hängt unser Wohlstand ab
für mich hat ich weiß andere war wegen
unsicher
was sagt der Markus wieder wenn ein Baum
umarmt ja
aber lieber als den Grünen liebe Freunde
für uns hat Klimaschutz den absoluten
Top Stellenwert
glaubwürdig mit denen die sich dafür
ankleben
normalerweise zu den klimaklebern nur
ein kurzes
gilt bei uns das als leben und leben
lassen deswegen würde ich sagen mai
leben und leben lassen irgendwo
[Applaus]
ein Parkplatz oder so wegen mir ja bei
schlechten Wetter ganz besonders gern
aber nicht und das sage ich ausdrücklich
wenn es um den Schutz von Eigentum und
von öffentlicher Sicherheit geht liebe
Freunde das sind wir konsequent jeder
der gegen bestehende Regeln verstößt
muss mit der Konsequenz des
rechtsstaatsrechnen auch und ganz
besonders in Bayern liebe Freunde
es gibt jetzt den einen an der Seite
mit dieser Ding und Bilder und so
was kann die alten Maler dafür ja aus
den Gulasch zu wenig schon
aber
sie haben doch einen ehrbares Motiv
sie sind doch Menschen die sich Sorgen
machen und konsequent leben wollen
sind wirklich alle klimakleber
konsequenten moralisch
nicht stört immer nur wisst ihr jeder
kann sein Meinung haben wir will völlig
enorm aber wenn das ganze mit doppelten
Boden stattfindet da wird es kritisch
klimakleber
die in Urlaub fliegen irgendwo nach
Thailand und Bali liebe Freunde wer mehr
Interesse an Miles and More statt am
Klimaschutz hat hat kein Recht hier zu
kleben mein Vorschlag ist fliegt doch
alle mal nach China klebt euch am Platz
des Himmlischen Friedensfest da hat er
mehr erreicht von Klimaschutz als in
Bayern den Verkehr aufzuhalten liebe
Freunde
wir brauchen euch nicht
noch mal zu Energie weil man dann schon
sind wir sind übrigens auch das Land des
nicht nur erneuerbare Energien ausbaut
wie kein zweites tatsächlich so
sondern wir sind noch das einzige Land
mit einer eigenen wasserstoffstrategie
Kraftwerke die wir bauen
Industrieprojekte Tankstellen wir müssen
auch Pipelines bauen warum
weil es die Bundesregierung ablehnt im
Leistungssatz Deutschlands im Süden es
gilt für Baden-Württemberg und Bayern
eigene zu legen
wir wollen es von Norden entwickeln und
man spürt es übrigens aus jeder Faser
des ampelkörpers egal wie groß oder
kleiner sein mag man spürt es richtig
die Abneigung gegenüber dem Süden sowie
Schröder einmal sagte ihr Bayern bekommt
nur Steine statt Brot machen die das
jetzt ganz genauso es gibt keinen
bayerische Ministerin oder Minister in
der Bundesregierung ich würde ja noch
verstehen wenn die Ampel sagt es gibt
keine qualifizierten grünen FDP oder
Sozis aus Bayern da gebe ich zu aber sie
machen es bewusst weil sie Bayern
benachteiligen wollen und das lassen wir
nicht so liebe Freunde niemals
und ein Beispiel
ein neues Beispiel
also Pipelines wollen sie nicht selbst
und dann kommst du jetzt aber her und
sagen und überhaupt
die Bayern müssen endlich höhere
Strompreise zahlen sei recht die
nordgrünen Feuer fordern und feiern sich
indem sie sagen die Bayern sollen
doppelt so Strompreise
die bayerischen Grünen Schweigen
übrigens dazu ganz interessant
jetzt Mensch zahlen wir wirklich zu
wenig sind wir Empfänger in Deutschland
müssten die anderen sich anstrengen für
uns
nun ein kleiner Blick auf die Bilanz des
Länderfinanzausgleich lässt einem dieses
Argument doch leichter
ja
ich baue es erst auf warte eine
bis 1980 hat Bayern Geld bekommen
3,4 Milliarden Euro in der ganzen Zeit
danke
Zeit der Zeit haben wir über
108 Milliarden Euro bezahlt
wir zahlen jetzt mittlerweile 10
Milliarden pro Jahr 10 als wir die Klage
eingereicht haben
sollte eine Reform bringen auf den
Grundig hat es nichts gewirkt wir zahlen
60% des gesamten deutschen
Länderfinanzausgleichs
Albert Bürger rechnet mir vor von zehn
Milliarden könnten wir für 600.000
Kinder kostenlose Kita haben
für fast 400.000 Menschen Pflegeplätze
fast 150.000 Lehrern Lehrer anstellen
und wir könnten die zweite Stammstrecke
zweimal bauen und in jedem Waggon eine
Minibar einbauen dafür liebe Freunde
und
wer bekommt es Geld
Länder wie Berlin oder Bremen aus dem
Länderfinanzausgleich bekommen seinen
Bürger aus den beiden Stadtstaaten über
1000 € jährlich quasi umgerechnet als
länderfinanzausweis
jetzt erwarte ich ja nicht eigentlich
dass jedes Mal wenn Bayern nach Berlin
kommen eigentlich ein spontanen Demo
sein müsste oder man sich aus
Dankbarkeit dort vor die bayerische
Vertretung anklebt das könnt ihr sein ja
aber es ist schon absurd wenn man sich
das überlegt wenn man von dort an
oratschläge bekommt die Leisten sich in
Berlin Dinge die wir nicht können
dann wiederum leisten sich Dinge die mir
gar nicht wollen
und Sie bekommen dann dafür auch eine
Quittung bei der Wahl und ich finde es
schon ziemlich hart nach der
Bundestagswahl hieß es wer die meisten
Stimmen bekommen hat muss regieren und
es sei unmoralisch wenn der
Zweitplatzierte in Anspruch erhebt und
jetzt trifft sich die gleiche linke
Kartell wieder um das Wahlergebnis zu
ignorieren ich kann nur eines sagen Frau
Kiffer sollte endlich und letztmals
ihren Stuhl räumen und das Ergebnis
demokratisch akzeptieren liebe Freunde
sowas Skandal
und wenn wir schon geben dann dürfen wir
auch ein Vergleich ansprechen
zur Sicherheit zum Beispiel lieber
Joachim großer Erfolg im letzten Jahr
seit 44 Jahren die niedrigste
Kriminalitätsrate in Berlin ist übrigens
damals
woran liegt es wie Silvesternacht war
kein Einzelfall seine lange Serie von
Ereignis zum einen liegt daran dass wir
mehr Polizei haben ja und alles was wir
Polizei machen einschließlich
Grenzpolizei und Reiterstaffel war ein
Erfolg wir bezahlen unsere Polizei
besser wir geben in eine bessere
Ausrüstung aber das wichtigste ist wir
stehen zu der Polizei und genau da ist
der Unterschied zu Berlin in Bayern gibt
es keine rechtsfreien Räume in Berlin
werden Polizistinnen Polizisten
angehalten wegzuschauen liebe Freunde
die müssen sich dort mehr ums schendern
statt um Gauner kümmern wer die was ist
denken Stative zu fangen Berlin sollte
die Hauptstadt der deutschen sein sie
ist die Hauptstadt der Chaoten da gehört
endlich aufgeräumt und zwar schnell und
rasch und konsequent
und sorry
wir geben gern aber irgendwann ich kann
nur eines sagen für so etwas und vor
allem wenn diese neue linke Regierung
bleibt geben wir kein Geld denn
bayerisches Geld ist besser Bayern
aufgehoben als in Berlin und umklagen
wir gegen diesen unfairen
Länderfinanzausgleich liebe Freunde der
muss endlich geändert werden
apropos
apropos Geld
die Ampel ist
die schlechtesten aber vor allem die
teuerste Regierung aller Zeiten
Hunderte von Milliarden Schulden
dass ein FDP-Minister der vorderwahl
behauptet wir FDP wir machen zwei Dinge
nie
Schulden und Steuern erhöhen
dass der jetzt über vier fast 500
Milliarden Schulden macht ist schon
beeindruckt
er entwickelt sich zum Schulden Christi
von Deutschland Schulden Christian und
dann macht er auch noch so Tricks herein
er nennt seine Schulden Vermögen
ja er nennt seine Schulden Vermögen
Journalisten
nach Christian Lindner ist der der die
meisten Schulden macht der reichste Mann
liebe Freunde
der letzte der das behauptet hat können
erinnern war der griechisch
kommunistische Finanzminister warufakis
ja dass die griechischen Kommunisten
irgendwann Blutsbrüder der FDP werden
hätte ich auch nicht gedacht liebe
Freunde
unseriös hochziehen
Bayern ist das Gegenmodell wir halten
die Schuldenbremse ohne Trick sein wir
haben gleichzeitig höchste
Investitionsquote und warum weil wir für
die nächste Generation Liebe ju wollen
dass ihr stark bleiben könnt Edmund
Stoiber hat den ausgeglichenen Haushalt
eingeführt und wir bleiben seinem Erbe
treu liebe Freunde wir halten den
Haushalt ohne Schulden und es bleibt
auch so
und wenn wir schon bei der FDP sind
eine weitere Enttäuschung gerade wird
gerade Gerede Übersteuern
keine Steuererhöhung aber sie haben die
Steuern schon erhöht die
Erbschaftssteuer endlich haben wir
gemerkt vor Weihnachten Notartermin zu
bekommen war nicht so einfach ja
klammheimlich hat Christian Lindner die
Erbschaftssteuer massive erhöht ohne
Freibeträge anzupassen
dass die FDP die Erbschaftssteuer erhöht
hätte ich niemals für möglich gehalten
das ist ein Stück von Wahlbetrug
liebevollen Freunde und die FDP
Brandenburg hatte mal in einem
Landtagswahlkampf folgendes Motto keine
Sau braucht die FDP ich sage euch wenn
jede selber sagen wollen wir in Bayern
nicht widersprechen liebe Freunde und
Freunde
diese neue Steuer ist unfair weil es
keine Erhöhung der Freibeträge nach zehn
Jahren gibt sie ist ungerecht weil
regionale Unterschiede nicht
berücksichtigt werden in Deutschland
haben wir unterschiedliche Preise in
Bayern ist am teuersten
Ilse bei ihrem Tegernsee der Grund auf
dem man die Klo steht ist teurer als
manches Wohnhaus in anderen Teilen
Deutschland liebe Freunde
und deswegen können sich Bayern nicht
mehr leisten dass Eigentum das Häuschen
dass sie von ihren Eltern vererbt
bekommen haben zu behalten sie müssen es
verkaufen und Spekulanten aus anderen
Teilen der Welt kaufen ganze Landstriche
in Bayern auf liebe Freunde das kann
nicht sein das ist der ausverkaufte
Heimat durch diese Erbschaftssteuer der
FDP die muss weg die Erbschaftssteuer
die muss verändert werden und da gegen
klagen wir
wisst ihr was ich an der Amt ist so
beeindruckend finde eins schon
sie ist ja relativ ziellos bei zentralen
Fragen der Politik aber sie ist total
zielstrebig beim Umbau der Gesellschaft
man spürt richtig wie sie da sich gut
verstehen sie wollen ein anderes Land
ein anderes Deutschland zum Beispiel bei
Drogen
wie absurd ist es eigentlich lange an
der Maske im Zug festzuhalten aber die
Droge auf der Straße gut zu finden
lieber Klaus holitschek alle warnen
Ärzte Polizei die Europäische Union
Manfred warens holländischen Freunde
Sankt tut nicht den gleichen Fehler
machen ich sage auch wenn der einen an
der glaubt er könnte aber eine Sitzungen
Gemeinderat deutlich entspannter
stattfinden ja
ich will für Bayern keine Drogen auf der
Straße und keinen Zugang für unsere
Kinder liebe Freunde Nein zu den Drogen
ich bin auch echt enttäuscht von dem
Mann Lauterbach ja
als Lichtgestalt gestattet zur Dauer
Nervensäge mutiert wenn man sieht denkt
man immer an Catweazle liebe Freundinnen
Freunde
und war der letzte denn noch in der
Corona Schleife war aber das hätte ich
noch gesagt mein Gott was soll's ist
vorbei aber lieber Klaus dass er jetzt
eine Vorschlag macht für die
krankenhausreform die für unzählige
Krankenhäuser im ländlichen Raum das
Ausbringen würden das werden wir nicht
akzeptieren wir sagen hände weg von
unseren Krankenhäusern im ländlichen
Raum wir lassen uns die Gesundheit in
Bayern nicht durch ein Lauterbach kaputt
machen liebe Freunde
diese Ampel
die will ein anderes Deutschland eine
andere Gesellschaft das Leitmotiv heißt
woknis
und cancel culture nicht Bock Alexander
das ist dass wir in Berlin Gemüse und
Essener
es droht tatsächlich eine düstere
wokwolke unseren weißblauen Himmel zu
verdunkeln
Idee haben es Befreiung gedacht ist doch
aber nichts anderes als zu illiberalen
Spießer zu montiert mit wilden
umerziehungsphantasien im Mittelpunkt
steht Sprache und Kultur die Grüne
fordern eine genderpflicht in Bayern
liebe Freundinnen Freunde meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren wir bleiben
bei der höflichen Anrede es darf jeder
reden was er will aber nicht gender
Pflicht in bayerischen Schulen und
Hochschulen lehnen wir ab ist mit der
CSU nicht zu machen
ist auch total abstrus ja wenn wir zu
unseren Schützen gehen Rede halten da
sind wir schon freundlich sagen die
beschützen Schwestern die beschützen
Brüder nein
das muss gechändert schützen brüderinnen
heißt
das Schützenkönig muss genannt werden
die treffsicherste Person
eine Hexe ist nach diesen neuen Regeln
eine Zauberkraft inhabende Person
wusste gar nicht dass jede Hexe
Zauberkraft hat ja
der Spion des Spion heißt es künftig
Auskunft schaffende Person
Familien werden verändert habt euch
schon mal erzählt Opa an oma wird Zorn
die Muttermilch soll Eltern Milch werden
auch da wusste ich gar nicht dass das
geht ja
und Eltern werden künftig nicht mehr
Vater und Mutter heißen sondern
Elternteil 1 und Elternteil 2 und meine
Herren sie können sich vorstellen welche
Nummer wir nach grüner Vorstellung dabei
bekommen ja
die Kultur ist am stärksten betroffen
sie kennen alle Bully Herbig den
großartigen regisseurenkommandanten der
sagte letzte der Fernsehsendung er würde
sich nicht mehr trauen seinen Film der
Schuh des manito zu machen
Winnie zu bedroht
aber das kann man den Gegenden
dann habe ich gesagt warum weil Winnetou
ein schöner Mann sein
was hat es jetzt mit dir
die Verbindung
wir haben uns zusammengeschaltet wir
stehen so wie die Tour aber Winnetou ist
ja nicht der erste und letzte Angriff
jeder weiter
schneewittchen und die sieben Zwerge
soll künftig heißen schneewittchen und
die sieben Gefährten
hört sich weniger nach Märchen als nach
einem sehr leichten Film Mann liebe
Freunde
ein Karpfen Bäcker wird in
Baden-Württemberg abgemahnt weil er
Indianer auf seine Kraft macht Jim Knopf
ich kenne alles schinden auf Lukas der
Lokomotive der muss sich wahrscheinlich
ändern in München hat man gesagt in
München hat man gesagt man darf wenn
jemand ohne Ticket fährt nicht mehr
schwarz fahren nennen es sei schwierig
ich frage mich wann man bei uns anfängt
zu sagen die CSU ist immer die schwarze
Partei sondern weil man nur in Bayern
sind wahrscheinlich die most indigene
Partei oder sonst schon sind ja
kein Unsinn nach dem anderen
oder mit Liedern mit Liedern Leila
da kriegen die Grünen ja
Skandal im Sperrbezirk völlig undenkbar
oder unkorrekt sind Lieder wie Dschingis
Khan oder Manfred Moskau ja Moskau
und es geht bei Kinderliedern weiter und
ich sag's jetzt bewusst so dass mir
keinen Kopf machen kann
die beiden Kinderlieder drei Punkt Punkt
Punkt mit dem Kontrast
oder Joachim noch schlimmer 10 kleine
ich bin sicher Claudia Roth schreibt im
Moment jeden einzelnen Text um liebe
Freundin ich kann ja nur sagen wir
wollen wirklich niemand verletzen und
wenn es gute Vorschläge gibt gerne aber
das ist doch nimmer normal das ist doch
völlig überdreht wir lassen uns von den
Grünen nicht Kultur und Sprache umsehen
nein nein nein
liebe Freunde
bei den Grünen sind ich habe sie heute
ja kaum erwähnt
die Grünen haben sich übrigens auch
wieder zurückendlich die sind wir
dennologisches Loch gekommen ja
sie haben völlig anderes Wertesystem nur
einige Forderungen der Grünen aus allen
Bundesländern die Grünen sind von
indianerverbot sie sind von
autowaschverbot sie sind von
fleischverbot Silvan böllerverbot sie
sind sogar für luftballonverbot liebe
Freunde
grün heißt Verbot grün heißt nein nein
nein
die Grünen sind heute die größten
Spielverderber und Stimmungskiller der
Nation und auch wenn sie es möchte und
sich anwidern wir machen keinen
schwarz-grünen Bayern liebe Freunde wir
wollen die Grünen nicht in der
bayerischen
wir sind
das gesellschaftliche Gegenmodell jeder
hat da klar die Linie nein steht für
Grün ja dafür stehen die CSU wir
bekennen uns zu der liberale tastbar
Ware bei uns heißt das leben und leben
lassen bei uns heißt es was blaue Stadt
Wok wir sind keine ampelspießer sondern
freiheitsdenkende Menschen bei uns soll
jeder nach seiner Fassung leben und
nicht nach der Grünen Pfeife tanzen wir
sind kein Zwangsstaat wir sind ein
Freistaat und dafür steht die CSU und
ich auch ganz persönlich dass wir dafür
kämpfen und das auch umsetzen liebe
Freunde
ich frage euch
was ist denn eigentlich attraktiver
das Ampel Berlin oder das CSU Bayern
das können wir ja sein dass er eine
Abstimmung mit den Füßen wenn übrigens
alles immer so stimmt was manche Medien
über Bayern schreiben und die Opposition
so sagt dann müsste es ja einen Exodus
aus Bayern geben müsst ihr alle fliehen
kennt ihr Aufnahmelager gestrandeter
geflurte Bayern in Castrop-Rauxel oder
Wanne-Eickel
noch kein Kind
ist Gegenteil willst du die kommen mir
alle zu uns man kann sagen man rennt uns
fast die Bude ein
ige suchen Schutz im wir gerne geben
aber die meisten suchen wir Glück liebe
Freunde
wir sind das glücksland
glücksatlas nicht jedes glücklich aber
immer mehr bei uns lebt man länger und
waren es lebt man besser in Bayern von
zehn Landkreisen mit der höchsten
Kaufkraft sind acht in Bayern und
deswegen kann ich nur eines sagen wenn
man mal alle Meinungen Kommentare
weglässt und einfach die Fakten anschaut
die Bayern Bilanz ist die beste in
Deutschland und es ist kein Zufall das
hängt mit dem Fleiß der Leute aber eben
auch mit einer guten Politik zusammen
und wer macht die gute Politik in Bayern
[Musik]
lasst uns die Fakten sehen und auch in
der Fragen Bayern ist stark weil wir die
stärkste Wirtschaft haben wir sind
absolut die Nummer eins in Deutschland
wir haben mehr Industriearbeitsplätze
als Nordrhein-Westfalen
niedrigste Arbeitslosenquote wir haben
die meisten Dax-Unternehmen acht Länder
in Deutschland haben überhaupt kein
Dax-Unternehmen
unser Bruttoinlandsprodukt ist größer
als alle Nordländer zusammen ist größer
als das von Tschechien Portugal und
Griechenland 90 Prozent aller Nationen
der Welt haben ein kleineres
Bruttoinlandsprodukt als wir und jeder
Bayer vom Baby der geboren ist bis zum
ältesten Bürger zusammengerechnet
erwirtschaftet pro Jahr einen Fünfer BMW
liebe Freunde und Freunde in anderen
Ländern reicht's zu sehr kleine Autos
aber in Bayern ist einfach eine andere
Liga und es muss endlich einmal
anerkennt und respektiert werden
und lieber Präsident der Handwerkskammer
wir haben auch die meisten Handwerker
25 Prozent aller Meister in Deutschland
kommen aus Bayern
und ich finde das Handwerk wird viel zu
wenig wertgeschätzt liebe Freunde ja
viel zu wenig wertgeschätzt
und deswegen haben wir uns bewusst
entschieden ein Signal zu setzen wir
setzen auf die Gleichheit von mastern
meistern weil lieber Markus blumig mit
manchen Begriffen bis heute fremde Maß
der Bachelor immer ganz ehrlich ja wenn
man draußen irgendwo jemanden fragt
die meistens der letzte war schön
aber egal wie man es nennt ihr versteht
was ich meine
und deswegen bauen wir
Berufsbildungszentren aus deswegen
machen wir erstmals einen Tag des
Handwerks und als erstes und einziges
Bundesland nehmen wir die
Gleichwertigkeit der Ausbildung ernst
wenn das Studium kostenlos ist dann muss
es die Meisterausbildung auch sein nur
bayern macht es leben Freunde sonst
niemand
also wir sind stark
unserem Namen mit drin wir sind die
christlich soziale Union
aber ist der Begriff der würde für mich
der Zentrale würde und wertschätzen
zwei Drittel der Bayern Glauben übrigens
dass es gerecht zugeht in Bayern
in Deutschland hat der gleichen Umfrage
Glauben zwei Drittel der Deutschen das
ist in Deutschland ungerecht sind
wir haben die niedrigste Armutsquote
Bremen hat einen 100% höhere Selbst NRW
50%
und wir kämpfen auch sehr für eine
gesunder dem ländlichen Raum ich habe es
angesprochen lieber Klaus lieber Markus
mehr Studienplätze für Medizin Gerhard
wird auch Passau helfen mehr
Studienplätze für Medizin als NRW und
Niedersachsen zusammen
wir sind fast die einzigen die
Pflegeplätze fördert in der letzten
Periode über 4.000 in der nächsten und
festgelegt über 8.000 aber das ist für
mich ganz entscheidend
nicht nur Pflegeplätze fördern sondern
auch die Pflege daheim
wer sind die größte Gruppe der
Pflegekräfte in Bayern
sind die Angehörigen
70 Prozent werden zu Hause gepflegt
Partner die anderen der liebevoll
pflegen Kindern die aufopferungsvolle
Eltern betreuen und mittlerweile auch
Enkel die mithelfen dass ihre Großeltern
ein schönen Lebensabend und genau für
die haben wir liebe Freundinnen Freunde
ein Pflegegeld eingeführt von 1000 Euro
das war damals der Wunsch und es
wichtigste Anliegen und zwar leider und
ich sagte es leider
verstorbenen Barbara Stamm sie fehlt uns
allen mir auch
aber anstatt dass die Opposition damals
danke sagt nein nein also heftig
kritisiert verschwendetes
Geld ich habe dann mal nachgeschaut ob
das stimmt aber Briefe gesehen habe mir
eine damals Niederbayern übrigens
geschrieben sie steht lieber mistert
danke danke für das Geld wir sind davon
von dem Geld zum Urlaub an die Nordsee
fahren
lacht sich naja Nordsee wenigstens nach
platt oder so wer ist braunschweben das
Geld ja dabei
vielleicht passt es hier nicht her aber
vielleicht passt es gerade hier
das mit Leidenschaft und Liebe zu tun
die Dame schrieb dass dieser 40 Jahren
mit ihrem Mann verheiratet ist
und dass ihr Mann Demenz erkrankt
für mich übrigens ganz persönlich die
wohl schlimmste Form der Erkrankung die
es gibt dass man quasi aus dem hellen
Licht ins halt dunkel geht nicht mehr
wissend wer man ist und wer die anderen
sind und für die Angehörigen einer der
schmerzhaftesten Erfahrungen der Pflege
wenn er geliebter Partner seine Eltern
eine Großeltern die nicht mehr kennen
die Dame schrieb jedenfalls
die Schritt
wir sind dahin gefahren weil wir damals
unsere erste Hochzeitsreise gemacht
und sie hatte den Eindruck gehabt dass
ihr Mann
dass ihr Mann in den Momenten ein kurzer
Form der Wiedererkennung ist Aufwachens
sozusagen aus dem Dämmerlicht des
vergessen werdens heraustrat und der
Erinnerungen hatte ich kann es nicht
beschreiben wie die Frau ist hat mir
damals das hat mich sehr sehr gerührt
weil es ist ein Zeichen von Liebe und
Respekt denjenigen gegenüber den anderen
pflegt
und deswegen lasse ich es niemals zu
dass wenn Menschen einander in Liebe
zugetan sind pflegen helfen
aufopferungsvoll in der Partnerschaft
stehen das dann manche Politiker darüber
abfällige Bemerkungen machen wir sind
das einzige und erste Bundeslandes ein
Pflegegeld hat und wir lassen das auch
weiter so weil wir das wertschätzen dass
Menschen füreinander tun es muss nicht
alles der Staat Regeln sind wir dankbar
das ist die Familie gibt liebe Freunde
werde oft gefragt
wofür steht die teso
wenn man nachts geweckt wird möchten wir
sofort drei Dinge sagen
die meisten ich kennen wenn sie nachts
sagen sehr interessante Dinge ja
aber ich sage immer drei Dinge nur in
der Landespolitik von Sicherheit gar
nicht zu schweigen drei Dinge gibt es
nur bei uns wir sind das ersten einzige
Bundeslandes ein Pflegegeld hat
wir sind das erste und einzige
Bundesland Familiengeld hat Kinder
bekommen zur A bis zur Einschulung und
3.000 Euro pro Jahr und wir werden als
ersten einzige Bundesland sein dass eine
kostenlose und kostenfreie
Meisterausbildung hatten jetzt sage ich
euch mal was das sind doch drei super
Gründe die CSU zu wählen liebe Freunde
Vergleich zu den ganzen anderen
[Applaus]
also wir sind stark wir sind sozial sind
sicher
wir sind auf smart
wir sind Hipp und modern mehr als die
meisten denken
alle 20 bis 25 Jahre
die Hubert kommt Bayern an so einen
Sprungpunkt
da stellt sich die Frage die Welt
verändert sich gehen wir mit machen wir
was draus oder fallen wir wieder zurück
es war bei Strauss und Goppel so es war
bei Edmund Stoiber Sohn ist heute
genauso wir haben uns übrigens immer für
Modernisierungen entschieden wir haben
uns immer für die Zukunft entschieden
heute dreht sich die Welt schneller denn
je
Wissenschaft und Forschung sind die neue
Währung und genauso wie im Fußball in
der Premier League Geld Tore schießt ist
es bei Forschung und Wissenschaft auch
unsere Freunde die USA lieber Timo sie
ihr verkauft uns nicht nur teures Gas
gutes Geschäft
dicke Freunde ja wenn die USA zeigt uns
wie es geht sie investieren in Forschung
und werben Wissenschaftler natürlich ab
und was ist die Antwort der Ampel darauf
sie kürzen den Forschungsetat
ist ungefähr genauso eine Politik im
Fußball wenn man sagen würde
wir fahren zum schwersten spielespiel
nur mit neuen Mann und eine Strategie
hat in der Vergangenheit nur der Club
und verfolgt sonst keiner ja
also Berlin kurz und was macht Bayern
wir klotzen
liebe Freunde ich weiß ob das den
meisten bewusst ist wir leben heute
immer noch von dem was in der Zeit
stoiberhuber investiert wurde für
Wissenschaft und Forschung davon leben
wir heute
und wir haben jetzt mit der Hightech
Agenda angesetzt mit über dreieinhalb
mittlerweile sind es fast 4 Milliarden
Euro die größte
technologieoffensive in der bayerischen
Geschichte gemacht wir investieren für
künstliche Intelligenz mehr als ganze
Länder Italien Spanien wir sind beim
Hochtechnologie Computing Supercomputing
mittlerweile an den technologiegedanken
Giganten Südkorea vorbei und ja ich
stehe auch zu Luft und Raumfahrt auch
wenn manch einer Maul das war bei
Strauss auch so Bavaria One ist ein
Erfolg fast 50 Prozent der ESA Aufträge
gehen ein Deutschland an Bayern und
lieber Markus Blume die Fakultät
explodiert gerade zur vorzulauf der
größten luft-
[Musik]
des Mondes dann müssen wir sich mehr
sehen liebe Freunde und Freunde da mache
ich mit
vor der Landtagswahl war mein Freund
Hubert auch ein Gegner ich habe ihn
jetzt zur Belohnung zum Raumfahrt
an Aliens
eigentlich nicht
aber als ich letzten in Aachen die
FDP-Politikerin Frau Agnes Strack
Zimmermann gesehen habe kam mir schon
Zweifel Liebe freundinnenfreunde kamen
mir schon gleiche
also
die heilige Agenda ist auch seit ganz
persönlich das Herzstück meiner Zukunft
Agenda es wird uns für die nächsten 20
Jahre Wettbewerbsvorteile bringen
es wird jetzt schon die Großen dieser
Welt Apple Google Microsoft vielleicht
auf Facebook kommen zu uns ich höre
jetzt immer wieder in den Zeitungen
kein Wunschdenken
die Wahrheit ist doch nicht dass eine
Kiel Rostock Hannover oder Bremen unsere
Gegner sind die konkurren mit London
Mumbai la und Shanghai und ich kann
allen nur mal raten die singen zieht den
Bayern die Läden Hosen aus zieht lieber
euch warm an denn die meiste des singen
gehen hinterher nackt nach Hause wir
werden diesen Wettbewerb gewinnen liebe
Freunde wir können euch aber einstellen
unsere Bayern Bilanz ist top
und das Bayern Gefühl das einzige gar
nicht denn wir bekennen uns und wir
betrachten es als Mutant zur Tradition
zu brauchen zur Heimat
als wir bei der Beerdigung von Papst
Benedikt waren war tief bewegen liebe
Freunde waren viele von euch dabei danke
da waren Gänsehautmoment als am Ende
dann der sagt in die Petersdom geführt
wurde gab es spontan Beifall ich durfte
oben bei den Staatsgästen stehen dann
hinter Scholz
und
plötzlich
physikalische Beschreibung ja
und plötzlich gab es Musik
es war nicht gar nicht mehr
plötzlich spielt er eine Blaskapelle die
Bayernhymne und von unten vom
Petersplatz er drang nach oben die
Bayernhymne ich selber habe dann mit
gesungen Olaf Scholz hat mich eigentlich
völlig entsetzt und schlumpfig
angeschaut
ich war total beeindruckt und stolz so
ein Moment den gibt es nur mit Bayern
liebe Freunde und Freunde nur
und dann lese ich immer wieder
aber Eiern ist international ja nicht
attraktiv
alles ist bei uns
man muss übrigens gar nicht die Welt
fahren wenn man in Bayern ist und bleibt
dann trifft man die Welt die kommt zu
uns gesid Münchener Sicherheitskonferenz
wieder riesen Sache
und da kommen sie Makro
Boris Johnson letztes
sympathisch bei der Frage als erstes was
gibt es zu trinken
jetzt kann man ja Harris am
beeindruckend war für mich immer ich
habe es oft erzählt aber ich mache es
einfach wieder
Präsident der USA letztes Jahr beim G7
Kamera wirklich beeindruckend man kennt
viele Staatsgäste wenn dann so die Air
Force One kommt ja schon was besonderes
also
Amerikaner kommt mit fast 1000 Mann
sogar die Gang USA
und Präsident beiden kamen runter würde
dynamisch freundlich Sam ich habe mich
herzlich begrüßt dann sah wir haben das
beste Aufgebot was man haben
Gebirgsschützen da fragte was ist denn
das WhatsApp sagte Varian Army ja
army
ist beeindruckend zwei Tage später
Leben des Entsetzen in Berlin lähmen
setzen in den linken Redaktionsstuben oh
Gott oh Gott nein in Berlin sagt man
jetzt entsteht in der Welt der Eindruck
so war die lesartung dass die glauben
die Welt dass alle Bayer alle deutschen
so aussehen wie die Bayern
alle deutschen sehen so aus wie Bayern
meine Antwort was für ein Imagegewinn
für Deutschland
[Applaus]
wir sind nicht perfekt und wir haben
eine Menge zu tun wir sind eine
überheblich aber da uns keinen andere
lobt müssen wir das manchmal auch selber
tun und ich sag nur eins wir sind das
bessere Deutschland und der alte Satz
gilt einfach jetzt nice to
Bierpreise Bayern er gilt auch heute
noch liebe Freundinnen Freunde
früher hieß es Laptop und Lederhose
manche sagen Leberkäse
Gigabit und Gamsbart
Raumfahrt und Rosenkranz fällt mir ja
oder Hightech mit Heimat oder Heimat mit
Herz wenn man uns beschreiben müsste uns
Bayern für alle die uns nicht so kennen
dann würde ich sagen wir sind trendy und
traditionell zugleich
wir sind lässig und leistungsstark
zugleich wir sind gemütlich und genial
das ist Bayern und ganz ehrlich ich sehe
überhaupt keinen Grund warum die Bayern
ein schlechtes Gewissen haben sollten
weil sie so sind es kommen viele
Menschen zu uns und alle freuen sich
hier zu sein ich kenne ganz wenige die
bewusst in grüne Länder fahren und darum
lassen wir unseren Lebensstil nicht
verändern und vorschreiben von anderen
liebe Freunde und Freunde der Bavarian
Way of Life wird fortgesetzt
so das ist
das sachliche Buch ausgebreitet die
ausgangsweise Ausgangslage für die
Landtagswahl im Herbst
ich bin optimistisch das gebe ich zu
nicht nur
wir haben ein tolles Team das will ich
ausführlich sagen es ist keine
one-men-show in jedem bayerischen Bezirk
haben wir tolle Persönlichkeit in
Unterfranken und unsere
digitalministerin Judith galler
in Oberfranken unsere Europaministerin
Melanie Hummel
in Mittelfranken mich auch ja aber
unsere sichere Bank und den
innovativsten Kostüm aussuche in
Veitshöchheim Joachim Hermann
in Schwaben unseren super
Gesundheitsminister Klaus holitschek
in Niederbayern und der Oberpfalz unsere
beiden Ostbayern Bomber auf der einen
Seite den besten Finanzminister in
Deutschland Albert bürgerpfalz
und den Niederbayern Christian
banreitner der deutlich mehr politisches
und tatsächliches Gewicht auf die Waage
bringt das andere Niederbayern
und in Oberbayern unsere wunderbare Ilse
Aigner fünf Minister zwei
Generalsekretäre liebe Freundin Freunde
nennt ihr mir mal Politiker anderer
Parteien zum Beispiel der SPD
der Spitzenkandidat der SPD den kennt
kaum einer und die die ihn kennen finden
in unsympathisch liebe Freunde und
Freunde
seine Ko-Vorsitzende sagte letzte in
einem Interview Florian von genau
sei sei einer der nettesten Menschen die
sie kennen war das schließ ich sie hat
einen sehr sehr kleinen bekannten Geist
was ich beim SPD-Vorsitzenden verstehe
liebevollen Freunde
wir haben tolle Leute so viele andere
die noch da sind ich habe jetzt so die
Spitzen nach der jeweiligen listenane
und wir haben auch einen anderen
Regierungsstil liebe Freundinnen Freunde
als die andere und zwar verlässlich
seriös und ohne dauerzeit und deswegen
ich sage ja wir setzen die Koalition in
München fort nicht mit den Grünen
sondern mit den Freien Wählern liebe
Freunde
ja und das war unsere Übertragung vom
politischen Aschermittwoch in Passau
zunächst erstmal das war die CSU mit dem
Parteivorsitzenden Markus Söder und ich
frage Roman Deininger von der
Süddeutschen Zeitung er ist ja einer der
Experten wenn es um das Thema CSU geht
wenn es um das Thema Markus Söder geht
wir hatten auf sie die Rede von Markus
Söder wohnt anderthalb Stunden dauert
ihr jetzt schon an gewirkt
oftmals die Positionen ich würde sagen
Markus Söder hat heute nichts
ausgelassen kein Ziel und keine Pointe
hat sicher auch die eher billigen
mitgenommen aber das ist ja was die
Parteibasis Aschermittwoch erwartet wir
haben eine Rede gehört die in ihrer
guten ersten Hälfte sich an der Ampel
abgearbeitet hat das alte södermotiv vom
Ampel Norden der dem angeblich freien
Süden um den Kragen will und erst so im
letzten Drittel der Rede hat er dann
seine Bilanz in Bayern in den
Mittelpunkt gestellt hat ja den Stolz
auf die schöne Bayernland geschworen und
insgesamt waren die effektiv war die
funktioniert hat beim Publikum viel
Applaus und viele einzelne klatschte
stellen aber es war keine Rede die
Überraschungen geworden hätte ich fand
am interessantesten dass er beim Thema
Migration etwas härter geworden hat aber
jetzt auch keinerlei Grenze hat der
ankomme beim Publikum war eigentlich die
Stelle also gemeinsam das zur deutschen
Staatsbürgerschaft auch deutsche
Sprachkenntnisse gehören das ist ein
alter Bierzelt Klassiker der CSU und der
hat auch heute funktioniert
er hat sich aber ja abgearbeitet vor
allen Dingen und das fand ich ganz
interessant an den Grünen also er hat ja
weniger die SPD und die FDP angegriffen
in seiner Rede sondern vor allen Dingen
grünen Umweltschutz Ziele und die NGOs
war das für Sie überraschen was bezweckt
er damit
die Grünen sind der Hauptgegner von
Markus Schröder in diesem
Landtagswahlkampf Söder ist ein
Politiker der so richtig nur
funktioniert und auch zu rhetorische
Form aufläuft wenn er jemand hat an dem
man sich reiben kann und in diesem
Wahlkampf in Bayern kann es keine
einzelnen Person sein es gibt keinen
Gegenkandidaten keine Gegenkandidatin
der oder die mit Söder auf Augenhöhe ist
es sind die Grünen als Partei als
gesellschaftliche Kraft deswegen also
diese überbordende Menge an Witzen über
das Gendern über vegane Ernährung und
viele andere Dinge die angeblich den
bayerischen Bayern von der ampelung von
den Grünen Bayern übergestimmt werden
sollen danke schön Roman Deininger von
der Süddeutschen Zeitung für diese
Einschätzung
danke Ihnen
ja und möchte es natürlich die Rede von
Markus Süder den csu-partei-chef auch
noch mal hier im Studio besprechen und
wir haben ja auch schon darüber
gesprochen Herr Decker Frank Decker
Politikwissenschaftler von der
Universität in Bonn
wären wir die Rede betrachtet haben er
hat die Grünen vor allen Dingen
angegriffen aber es war auch keine
wirklich staatstragende rede dir da
gehalten hat also so richtig hier
empfohlen für bundespolitische Aufgaben
hat er sich nicht oder sehen Sie das
anders also staatstragende reden werden
am politischen Aschermittwoch ohne hin
nicht gehalten und man muss natürlich
auch den
Kontext noch einmal betrachten
es war ja recht überraschend dass es
2021 dann zu einem recht einem Wechsel
kommt in Richtung SPD eigentlich hatte
sich alles darauf eingestellt dass es
eine schwarz-grüne Regierung gibt oder
eine Jamaika Koalition und Söhne hatte
selber beworben diese anzuführen und
dass er sich jetzt so an den Grünen
abarbeiten kann
im Bund ja hätte regieren müssen das
liegt eben daran dass man eben jetzt
nicht mit den Grünen regieren muss man
ist im Bund in der Opposition und das
hat es ihm natürlich hier erleichtert
auch die Grünen massiv auch mit
bundespolitischen Themen
anzugreifen und der andere Punkt ist
dass seine Ausgangsposition doch jetzt
in Bayern so gut ist dass er darauf
setzen kann ohne die Grünen regieren zu
können wenn das nicht so wäre dann
müsste er natürlich da auch bisschen
vorsichtiger sein denn eine Partei zu
verteufeln mit der man dann am nächsten
Tag koalieren muss müsste das wird
schwierig und die Grünen sind haben wir
eben auch gehört
sind der Hauptgegner für die CSU die
muss ja im Grunde an zwei Fronten
kämpfen interessant fand ich bei der
Rede das zwar das Thema Migration
angesprochen wurde aber die AFD als
Konkurrent die AFD ist ja
bundespolitisch auch in Bayern auch im
Aufwind also sich profitiert auch von
diesen Krisen Themen die AFD hat er
überhaupt nicht erwähnt dann haben wir
die FDP die ist allerdings sehr schwach
in Bayern und die Freien Wähler hat er
ja im Grunde am Schluss auch als
Wunschkoalitionspartner bezeichnet also
überhaupt keine Rede mehr von einer
Alleinregierung da haben wir also die
Konkurrenz auf der einen Seite und auf
der anderen Seite machen die Grünen der
CSU aber auch Konkurrenz nicht nur in
den Großstädten sondern zum Teil auch im
ländlichen Raum also das Thema
Landwirtschaft hat ja auch eine große
Rolle gespielt da gibt es durchaus auch
Landwirte die vielleicht dieser Idee
ökologischer Landwirtschaft durchaus auf
großen gegenüber stehen also er hat
diesen diese Auseinandersetzung heute
eigentlich nur an der einen Front
geführt nämlich in Richtung der Grünen
es gab eine Ausnahme da hatte sich an
der FDP abgearbeitet bei dem Thema
Erbschaftssteuer und das ist natürlich
ein Thema wo bayerische Landesinteressen
sehr stark tangiert sind das steht
natürlich für ein CSU-Politiker immer im
Vordergrund eben auch die bayerischen
Interessen auch die bayerischen
Interessen im Bund in den Vordergrund zu
stellen da wollte ich nämlich auch noch
mal drauf hinaus auch noch mal einhaken
warum funktioniert das eigentlich in
Bayern so gut mit diesem Gefühl Bayern
first das ist ja wirklich schon er hat
ja gesagt nicht Deutschland und die USA
hat ja von Bayern und den USA
beispielsweise die die bayerische
US-amerikanischen Beziehungen von so
etwas hat er ja gesprochen das würde ja
so kann man sich das zumindest in
anderen Bundesländern doch kaum
vorstellen dass das so funktioniert
würde also das hat ja eine gewisse aus
der Tradition das beginnt ja schon mit
der Bezeichnung als Freistaat also diese
Betonung auch der
Eigenständigkeit
und das wird ja auch zum Ausdruck
gebracht dass es eine eigenständige
christdemokratische Partei oder
christliche Partei in Bayern gibt das
war schon in der Weimarer Republik so
und im Kaiserreich also das die
Zentrumspartei hieß in Bayern bayerische
Volkspartei und die CSU hat es in einem
ganz besonderen Maße geschafft eben auch
Bayern mit sich selber zu identifizieren
auch dass sie im Bundes lange Zeit
mitregiert hat hat ja in Bayern sehr
stark genutzt und heute ist ja umgekehrt
dann kritisiert worden das kann man aber
wenn man im Bund in der Opposition ist
dass Bayern benachteiligt wird durch die
Ampel Regierung und ein Dauer Thema ist
natürlich der Länderfinanzausgleich
Bereich an deren Reform aber die CSU als
sie selber in der Bundesregierung war in
der letzten
Legislaturperiode selber mitgewirkt hat
Dankeschön für diese Einschätzung soweit
und ja wir verlassen jetzt erstmal
Bayern wir verlassen die CSU und gehen
nach Hessen dort feiert nämlich die
hessische SPD ihren politischen
Aschermittwoch auch Hessen befindet sich
ja im Wahlkampf mit einer
Spitzenkandidatin Nancy fazer und vor
Ort in Frankfurt dort ist der
SPD-Parteivorsitzende das klingt mal er
hat seine Rede vor wenigen Minuten
begonnen und wir zeigen die Ihnen
natürlich von Anfang an
wahnsinnig gefreut dass ich endlich mal
wieder auf einer politischen
aschermittwochsveranstaltungen sein kann
großer Dank an Karl Lauterbach dass er
endlich wieder zulässt dass wir uns
treffen dass wir zusammenkommen
dass das Ganze möglich ist und
eigentlich hatte ich mir vorgenommen vor
allem hier zu seinem Mike zu
unterstützen für die
Oberbürgermeisterwahl am 5 März aber ich
habe Mike nach deinen Worten irgendwie
das Gefühl ich muss hier gar nicht
unterstützen weil alle schon wissen du
hast eine Idee du weißt was du in
Frankfurt machen willst wenn man auf
deine Biografie guckt das ist
beeindruckend das ist für mich ich will
das hier sagen du verkörperst mit das
moderne Deutschland und du hast das Herz
im richtigen Fleck das hat man auch
gemerkt du verbindest wirtschaftliche
Kompetenz mit sozialen Zusammenhalt mit
Aufbruch hier für Frankfurt lieber Mike
und deswegen will ich dir mit voller
Überzeugung sagen du bist der richtige
für diese Stadt und deswegen bin ich mir
auch sehr sehr sicher wirst du am Ende
diese Oberbürgermeisterwahl gewinnen
hier sind viele die dich unterstützen
ich kann dir das für mich nur sagen
aber du hast hier
du hast dir lieber Mike du hast ja
absolut überzeugt
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde liebe
Genossinnen und Genossen ich habe lange
überlegt wie man so eine politische
aschermittwochsrede hält in Zeiten wie
sie sind und von fünf Minuten den Weg
hierher geguckt was in Passau so
passiert
Markus Söder erlebt in den fünf Minuten
hat er erzählt warum Bayern das tollste
Beste Bundesland ist ich habe mich dann
gefragt warum wollte er da eigentlich
vor zwei Jahren weg
meiner schafft auch nicht das schafft
auch nicht jeder an Armin Lasche zu
scheitern das ist schon eine besondere
Leistung wenn du nicht mal gegen Armin
Laschet Kanzlerkandidat wirst
aber ich habe mir
[Applaus]
ich habe mir dann schon gesagt du kannst
in diesen turbulenten und krassen Zeiten
in denen wir gerade politisch sind nicht
so diese typische aschermittwochsrede
halten wo man einfach 2025 Minuten auf
den politischen Gegner drauf klopft das
werde ich natürlich auch in der ein oder
anderen Stelle wo es wirklich notwendig
ist tun
aber ich möchte einfach auch die ernsten
Themen ansprechen die gerade da sind und
das kann man nicht links oder rechts
liegen lassen in diesen politischen
Zeiten den wir uns bewegen und man was
war das für ein Jahr das Kabel und ich
im Bundestag hinter uns haben die neue
Regierung und es ging von Tag eins an
los vielfältige komplexe Krisen die
Pandemie die noch nicht vorbei war und
das immer noch nicht ist auch wenn wir
glaube ich gerade über den größten Berg
rüber sind der Krieg der ausgebrochen
ist die Energiekrise die Inflation die
steigenden Lebensmittelpreise die
weltpolitischen Umbrüche die
Herausforderung für den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt und
jetzt gerade in den letzten Tagen dieses
grausame furchtbare Erdbeben was wir in
der Türkei und in Syrien sehen mussten
ich bin Nancy fazer sehr dankbar dass
sie gestern mit Annalena baerbock da
dass da war dass sie für Deutschland
noch mal die volle Solidarität und
Unterstützung zugesagt hat und ich
selbst hat mich gestern in einem Wort
mit meinem Wahlkreis mit einer
Fußballmannschaft türkischen und
kurdischen Mitgliedern getroffen die
jetzt am Samstag ich bin es jetzt
Turnier organisieren um dort auch
Spenden zu sammeln die dann selbst in
die Region fahren werden und das ist ja
nichts was
geografisch weit weg von uns passiert
ist sondern etwas was mitten in unserer
Gesellschaft auch ins Herz getroffen hat
weil wir doch so viele Menschen auch in
unserem rein kennen die dort Angehörige
die Verwandte die Freunde dort haben in
diesen Erdbebengebieten und ich will
einfach in einer aschermittwochsrede
auch an das Leid derjenige erinnern und
hier aber auch sagen dass ich dankbar
bin wie viel Hilfsbereitschaft
Spendenbereitschaft wie viel
Unterstützung aus Deutschland
organisiert wurde ein großer Dank an
alle die das organisiert haben die
mitgeholfen haben und in diesen
schwierigen Stunden wirklich auch bei
den Angehörigen und all den Opfern und
ihren Familien in der Türkei dabei sind
es sind
es sind wahnsinnig turbulente Zeiten ich
meine ich erinnere mich daran als ich in
die Politik gekommen bin da haben wir
teilweise
wochenlang gestritten über nichtige
Themen ich erinnere mich daran wir haben
wochenlang gestritten über 10 Euro
Praxisgebühr
jedes Jahr gibt es die Debatten über die
Umstellung von der Winter auf die
Sommerzeit und das füllt vier Wochen
lang die Zeitung
tanzverbote an karfreitagen auch eine
gern gesehene politische Diskussion und
auf einmal sind wir heute wieder in
einer Zeit in der wir reden über die
großen Fragen über Krieg und Frieden
über soziale Gerechtigkeit über die
Frage schaffen wir dass die
Arbeitsplätze hier in Deutschland zu
halten die Industriearbeitsplätze mike
hat Mike hat davon gesprochen also
Zeiten auch in denen große Sorgen und
Unsicherheiten da sind in denen Politik
auch Orientierung geben muss und ich
will das für mich hier mal in aller
Deutlichkeit sagen ich bin froh dass in
diesen Zeiten Olaf Scholz unser
Bundeskanzlerin ich bin froh
[Applaus]
das Olaf Scholz unser Kanzler ist
jemand
der die Akten liest der die Dinge
durchdringt der nicht morgens aufsteht
und sich fragt welche Sau jage ich jetzt
als nächstes durchs Dorf welche
Überschrift muss ich produzieren ja Olaf
Scholz ist kein Donald Trump und kein
Boris Johnson aber ich will ihn und euch
sagen genau deswegen bin ich froh dass
er in diesen schwierigen Zeiten unser
Bundeskanzler ist und das Land anführt
und wenn wir
glaube ich nehme das jetzt einfach mal
in die Hand
ich nehme es einfach mal in die Hand
glaube ich das ist vielleicht am besten
und wenn wir dann heute nach Passau
gucken und das waren diese paar Minuten
die ich gesehen habe und auch der Tenor
der letzten Tage dann muss man ja
eingestehen Markus Söder hat einen noch
viel größeres Problem mit diesem Land
entdeckt also Krieg Inflation
Energiekrise Corona das beschäftigt uns
schon alles aber Markus Söder hat jetzt
identifiziert die letzten Tage was
wirklich bedrohlich ist für die
westliche Zivilisation Gesellschaft das
Gendern
das ist das was der die letzten Tage
verbreitet hat das Gendern
und wisst ihr liebe Freunde ich bin das
Leid das so politisch Diskussion geführt
werden dass er sich jetzt hinstellt auf
die Bühne und davon redet dass er sich
dass er sich nicht zwangsumerziehen
lässt und wie absurd und albern ist das
eigentlich ich meine ich sag euch mal so
agiert man politisch wenn man von der
eigenen Bilanz ablenken will lasst uns
doch mal drüber reden was in Bayern
passiert im Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien gar nichts ich glaube bei euch
in Hessen übrigens mit dieser
Landesregierung ist auch nicht besser
oder ein Baden-Württemberg oder waren
das aber
lass uns
lass uns doch mal drüber reden was in
Bayern oder in anderen Ländern wo die
Union was zu sagen hat passiert im
Bereich des sozialen Wohnungsbaus nichts
lasst uns doch mal drüber reden das ist
diejenigen sind die heute über die
größte Gefahr des genderns reden die
nicht in der Lage waren 12 Euro
Mindestlohn mit zu entscheiden im
Deutschen Bundestag liebe Genossinnen
und Genossen liebe Freunde die lenken
mit ihren Kultur Kämpfen von ihrer
miserablen Politik ab und ich sage euch
wir lassen den das nicht durchgehen wir
reden über den Ausbau der Erneuerbaren
über sozialen Wohnraum wir reden über
gute Löhne und wir machen nicht deren
Politik mit
[Applaus]
und ich denke ja Angela Merkel wird
jeden Tag zu Hause sitzen und sich
schämen für das was mittlerweile in
ihrer Partei passiert ich meine das ist
keine moderne Politik das sind jetzt die
Jungs die holen wieder die alten
konservativen Parolen raus die Spalten
das Land zuletzt an Silvester als man
versucht hat in Berlin nach Vornamen zu
sortieren ich meine das hat doch mit dem
modernen Deutschland nichts zu tun damit
kriegst du in Passau vielleicht 1000
Leute von der CSU begeistert oder ein
Stammtisch der Jungen Union im Sauerland
aber das hat liebe Genossen und genossen
mit dem modernen Deutschland nichts mehr
zu tun Söder und März sind 30 Jahre zu
spät in diesem Land und das ist gut dass
die Republik mittlerweile weiter ist als
die Konservativen die wir dort sehen
[Applaus]
und das Land
ich habe es gerade gesagt wir sind durch
eine schwere Zeit durchgegangen aber ich
will ja auch betonen wir können stolz
sein auf das was wir geschafft haben ich
wusste Mitte letzten Jahres nicht ob wir
garantieren können dass alle genug
Energie im Winter haben ich habe mir
Sorgen gemacht die Gasspeicher voll sind
ob alle Ihre Stromrechnung und die
Gasrechnung bezahlen können und dann
haben wir uns aber mit Olaf Scholz an
der Spitze auf den Weg gemacht die
Gasspeicher waren voll wir haben es in
200 Tagen geschafften lng-terminal in
Wilhelmshaven bei mir Niedersachsen
hochzuziehen um Gas zu haben und das
jetzt auch zu nutzen wir haben im
Bundestag drei entlastungspakete auf den
Weg gebracht 100 Milliarden insgesamt ja
da mag es an der ein oder anderen Stelle
Kritik geben und das ein oder andere kam
zu spät oder wurde immer noch nicht
umgesetzt und wir machen da Druck als
SPD aber wir konnten 100 Milliarden in
die Hand nehmen und haben dafür gesorgt
dass wir gut durch diese Zeit
durchgekommen sind und ich meine ist
doch ein offenes Geheimnis dass die AFD
drauf gehofft hat dass der Wut Herbst
und der Wut Winter kam
ich weiß nicht ob ihr das gesehen habt
diese Sequenz als die vergessen haben in
Videos streamen auszuschalten die
afd-abgeordneten und nachzuhören war
dass die hoffen dass es richtig brutal
wird im Winter damit die Menschen
massenhaft auf die Straße gehen meint
diese Partei mag Deutschland nicht die
liebt Deutschland nicht die wollen das
Land Spalten die hoffen dass es den
Menschen schlecht geht dafür steht die
AFD das ist eine Schande für Deutschland
diese Partei und das hat sich in dieser
Sequenz offenbart
aber wir
aber wir waren ist liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde
wir waren es sie dagegen gehalten haben
das waren schwierige Entscheidung aber
wir haben es geschafft dass der
wutherbst und der Wut Winter dass das
abgewendet wurde wir sind noch nicht
vorbei mit der Krise und wir haben noch
viel zu tun und wir müssen noch vieles
auf den Weg bringen aber wir können da
ein bisschen stolz darauf sein dass wir
das mit Olaf Scholz an der Spitze
geschafft haben und ich möchte dass wir
genau auch diese Zuversicht dass wir die
ausstrahlen dass wir die Dinge verändern
können dass wir manchmal ein bisschen
brauchen und politische Entscheidung zu
treffen aber am Ende dann die richtigen
Entscheidungen für die Menschen in
diesem Land treffen und ich will ja auch
sagen wir haben das auch getan in der
Frage wie Stärken Menschen unsere
Bundeswehr 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen
die auf den Weg gebracht haben ich war
jetzt in dieser Woche am Montag mit
Boris Pistorius unserem neuen
Verteidigungsminister unterwegs sind ich
kann euch nur sagen der Boris macht ein
richtig guten Job er macht einen guten
Job und wir können froh und dankbar sein
wir können froh und dankbar sein
[Applaus]
dass er dass er zu uns auf die
Bundesebene gekommen ist
und jetzt lese ich heute morgen wieder
dass die Union nicht zufrieden ist damit
wieder Verteidigungshaushalt
ausgestattet ist und da mehr oben drauf
gepackt werden muss und wenn Boris sagt
zehn Milliarden sagen die 15 wisst ihr
ich würde den raten dass die mal ein
bisschen in Demut gehen dass sie sich
mal ein bisschen überlegen auch was die
eigentlich gemacht haben als die 16
Jahre lang die Spitze des
Verteidigungsministeriums gestellt haben
ich war da ja 12 Jahre im Ausschuss und
bin immer noch im Verteidigungsausschuss
du hattest manchmal den Eindruck dass
Verteidigungsminister der CDU dass sie
direkt aus der Anti militaristischen
Bewegung kommen und dafür sorgen dass
nichts mehr funktioniert in der Truppe
da ist kein Hubschrauber mehr geflogen
dass kein Panzer mehr gefahren der
Verteidigungshaushalt ist immer
untergegangen und ich sag euch mal von
denen brauchen wir keine Hinweise wie
man ordentliche Politik für die
Bundeswehr macht liebe Genossen ist
[Applaus]
und Demut
ist glaube ich generell so das Stichwort
das Friedrich Merz und Markus so dass
ich mal ein bisschen hinter die Ohren
schreiben sollten ich meine ich habe es
bei Söder gerade schon gesagt der ist
dann Armin Laschet gescheitert
und Friedrich Merz ist ja
erst dann Merkel gescheitert
dann wollte er Parteivorsitzender werden
ist dann Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer
gescheitert und wollte dann noch mal
Parteivorsitzender werden es auch in
Armin Laschet gescheitert am Ende hat er
gegenherge braun gewonnen also im
vierten Anlauf das ist ja eigentlich
eine sehr sozialdemokratische Geschichte
wenn du immer wieder fällst und
aufstehst und kämpfst aber ich finde das
darf nicht dazu führen dass man jetzt so
übermotiviert ist
wisst ihr als ich in den Bundestag
gekommen bin 2009 waren wir gerade in
der Opposition sind wir in die
Opposition rein das war ein vier Jahren
den wir
Oppositionen
und ich wollte richtig Gas geben und
immer drauf hauen auf Schwarz-Grün und
Schwarz-Gelb schwarz-Gelb ist manchmal
nicht so klar zu erkennen der
Unterschied zwischen den beiden
Konstellationen
[Applaus]
wollte
da einmal richtig draufhauen und dann
hat Frank Walter Steinmeier unser
damaliger Fraktionsvorsitzender mich zur
Seite genommen hat gesagt nee Lars wir
sind in großen Krisen damals ging es um
die Finanzpolitik die europäische
Finanzpolitik hat gesagt erst das Land
dann die Partei so machen wir das und
wissen ich würde mir wünschen manchmal
dass die jetzige Opposition die Union
auch so denkt und handelt erst das Land
dann die Parteien nicht den Rasen kaputt
treten nicht an jeder Stelle versuchen
immer das noch schlecht zu machen
sondern auch mal unterstützen in diesen
anstrengenden Zeiten in denen wir sind
vielleicht bleibt das nur ein Wunsch
aber ich will diesen Appell an die Union
richten denken mal darüber nach ob nicht
ein bisschen mehr Demut auf manchmal
angebracht ist
[Applaus]
liebe Genossinnen und Genossen
und das sage ich vor allem in einer
Phase wo wir sehen jeden Tag wie brutal
dieser Krieg unseren Kontinent unser
Zusammenleben und die politische
Landschaft verändert ich bin ich bin 44
Jahre alt
es fühlt sich gut an heute ist der
letzte Tag wo ich das noch sagen kann
dass ich 44 Jahre alt bin morgen ändert
sich das
aber ich hätte nicht gedacht ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass ich in meinem Alter
noch mal erleben muss dass es in der
Mitte Europas ein völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriffskrieg durch eine Großmacht gibt
die brutal versucht mit militärischem
Einsatz Grenzen zu verschieben ich hatte
gehofft ich muss das nicht erleben und
ich will das hier auch in aller Klarheit
sagen man mag viel darüber diskutieren
welche Fehler wir auch in der
Vergangenheit gemacht haben welche
Fehler wir im Umgang mit Russland
gemacht haben welche Fehler der Westen
im Umgang mit Russland gemacht hat aber
diese Aggression dieser Krieg geht von
einer Person aus und diese Person heißt
Vladimir Putin und der trägt die
Verantwortung dafür er wird als
Kriegsverbrecher in die Geschichtsbücher
eingehen und das benennen wir auch in
aller Deutlichkeit putin ist derjenige
von dem dieser Krieg aus geht er
Verantwortung er muss ihn beenden und
wir werden dafür sorgen dass er am Ende
vor den Gerichten dieser Welt für diesen
brutalen Krieg zu Verantwortung gezogen
wird jede genossen ist
[Applaus]
und wir stehen
wir stehen als
Westen seit Tag eins zusammen morgen
übermorgen wenn sich der Jahrestag
ergibt für diesen brutalen Krieg werden
wir das zehnte sanktionsverkehr auf den
Weg bringen das sind Sanktionen die
Russland Hardt treffen die die russische
Elite treffen wir stehen zusammen was
den politischen Druck angeht das erlebt
ihr in diesen Tagen auch dass wir jetzt
auch durch den Besuch von Joe Biden in
Polen das ist eine klare Allianz gibt
die weit über Europa hinausgeht Putin zu
zeigen dass er diesen Krieg beenden muss
und dazu gehört auch dass wir Waffen
liefern das ist keine Entscheidung die
wir uns leicht machen das ist doch eine
Entscheidung die man diskutieren muss
aber ich sag euch in aller Klarheit am
Ende eine Entscheidung die richtig ist
dass wir die Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
die mutig kämpfen dass wir Sie
unterstützen in ihrem Recht sich selbst
zu verteidigen das ist eine richtige
Entscheidung liebe Genossen und genossen
dass wir Waffen an die Ukraine liefern
aber dass wir
dass wir immer wieder erleben mussten
wie diese
waffenlieferungsdebatte sich
überschlagen haben
das will ich hier schon mal deutlich
ansprechen das hat mich manches Mal
verwundert um das höflich auszudrücken
da gab es denn Kollegen der Grünen die
kannten die Bundeswehr bisher nur weil
sie gegen sie demonstriert haben die
saßen auf einmal in den Talkshow als die
größten waffenexperten da hast du
manchmal das Gefühl gehabt nächstes Jahr
marschieren die mit dem Ostermarsch
direkt auf den Truppenübungsplatz wenn
das so weitergeht
und ich habe erlebt dass man
Diskussionen in keinerlei Sachlichkeit
mehr führen konnte wenn ich in Talkshows
gesessen habe und einfach nur darauf
hingewiesen habe dass Vladimir Putin ja
auch Atomwaffen besitzt dann ist das
gleich als Argument genutzt worden dass
man nicht an der Seite der Ukraine steht
das ist aber nicht der Fall wir sind da
sehr klar als SPD-Bundestagsfraktion als
Bundesregierung auch Olaf Scholz ist ja
klar aber ich sage euch wenn wir
Diskussionen über die Frage was passiert
da eigentlich gerade und wie verhält man
sich und was ist der nächste Schritt
wenn man da nur noch in Schwarz-Weiß
drüber diskutiert wenn man nicht mehr
abwägen darf dann machen wir auch
Diskussionskultur in diesem Land kaputt
und was ich überhaupt nicht
was ich überhaupt nicht
was ich überhaupt nicht akzeptieren kann
und das sage ich auch als jemand der die
große Ehre hat in einem Amt zu sein dass
mal Willy Brandt gehört ist das sich in
den letzten Wochen erlebt habe wie
Diplomatie und militärische Stärke
gegeneinander gestellt haben diejenigen
die den Begriff diplomatieren den Wunden
in Mund nehmen auf einmal verächtlich
angeguckt werden oder kritisiert werden
nein ich sag euch mit voller Überzeugung
das war richtig das Olaf Scholz nach
China gefahren ist und dass er dort ein
klares Signal gegen die nukleare
Bedrohung auch mit dem chinesischen
Staatspräsidenten gesetzt hat das war
richtig dass wir das Getreide Abkommen
haben verhandeln lassen auch mit der
russischen Seite weil das viele tausend
Menschen Leben gerettet hat dass die das
Getreide rausgekommen ist dass der
Ukraine es war richtig das Olaf Scholz
zum G20 Gipfel gefahren ist und dort mit
wichtigen Partnern eine
Regierungserklärung mit anderen gegen
Wladimir Putin und diesen Krieg erklärt
hat das ist auch richtig ich will das
jemand sagen dass er mit Wladimir Putin
telefoniert als deutscher Bundeskanzler
wir müssen doch aufpassen dass wir uns
nicht verzweigen der internationalen
Politik wenn wir sagen der Kanzler darf
dort nicht mehr aktiv sein der ruft den
doch nicht an um ihm zu sagen dass er
ein toller Typ ist der ruft ihn an um
ihm zu sagen dass er diesen brutalen
Krieg beenden muss liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde das ist das was ich erwarte von
einem Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und wir lassen als
Sozialdemokratin und Sozialdemokraten
nicht zu das militärische Stärke und
Diplomatie gegeneinander gestellt werden
für uns als Partei Willy Brandt gehört
beides zusammen liebe Genossen und
genossen
[Applaus]
und dann
und dann geht es neben dem Krieg in
diesen Tagen um ein anderes großes Thema
die Modernisierung des Landes Mike du
hast das schon wahnsinnig viel gesagt
und ich kann bei all den Vorschlägen die
du gemacht hast eigentlich nur ein Haken
dran machen sagen sollten wir so machen
und die Ampel ist damit gestartet ich
habe es vorhin gesagt ich will es nur
erklären von Tag eins an Krisen aber wir
hatten einen Koalitionsvertrag der für
mich auch nach wie vor gilt und der
richtig ist und wir müssen Fortschritt
Wagen und die große Modernisierung
dieses Landes voranbringen das ist die
Aufgabe die wir jetzt haben trotz Krise
die Modernisierung voranzutreiben
wir reden über Digitalisierung über
Verwaltungsmodernisierung über Planungs-
und genehmigungsbeschleunigung wir reden
von moderner Infrastrukturen von
innovativer Klimapolitik und alle kennen
diese Beispiel ich kennen die auch aus
meinem Wahlkreis wo die Windkraftanlage
18 Jahre dauert bis die genehmigt ist
oder du hast auch viele Verfahren
angesprochen was war es die Toilette die
zwei Jahre dauert da wollen die Leute
nicht mehr hören dass wir die Probleme
beschreiben sondern sie wollen dass wir
das Lösen sag euch auch mal die Menschen
wollen stolz sein auf die Infrastruktur
wir hatten mal in Deutschland die
modernste Infrastruktur vor 30 Jahren
und da müssen wir wieder hinkommen das
muss der Anspruch sozialdemokratischer
Politik sein dass wenn eine
Infrastruktur haben in diesem Land dass
die Leute stolz sind dass der zu
pünktlich kommt dass das Mobilfunknetz
funktioniert
dass das Internet schnell ist das ist
das was sie umsetzen müssen und da sage
ich hier auch mal sehr deutlich wenn ich
entscheiden kann als sozialdemokratische
Vorsitzender ob ich
Investitionen Infrastruktur und in
Bildung und in den sozialen Zusammenhalt
mache oder sage die Schuldenbremse gilt
dann weiß ich was für mich gilt wir
wollen dieses Land modernisieren liebe
Genossen und genossen und das ist jetzt
das was wir vorantreiben müssen
die Deutschland
die Deutschland Geschwindigkeit haben
wir jetzt gesehen beim lng-terminal in
Wilhelmshaven das war ein schönes Bild
als Scholz Habeck und Lindner da vorne
in diesem gelben Jacken standen 200 Tage
das muss jetzt überall anders aber auch
gelten dass wir in dem Tempo jetzt
verankern kommen muss nicht überall 200
Tage sein aber deutlich schneller als
das bisher der Fall ist und das gilt
dann z.B auch für die Industriepolitik
mike hat angesprochen das ist hier bei
euch in Frankfurt ein wichtiges Thema
auch in anderen Ecken der Republik wir
können froh sein dass wir so eine starke
Industrie haben und die Kollegen von
binding sind hier wir können froh sein
dass wir eine solche starke Industrie
haben aber ich erlebe auch politische
Kräfte die sagen wir uns ja nicht
schlimm wenn die Industrie aus
Deutschland verschwindet dann haben wir
immer was fürs Klima getan das ist nicht
die Lösung liebe Genossen und Genossen
ich möchte dass wir mit der Industrie
mit der Wirtschaft auf Klimaneutralität
setzen dass wir auf Innovation auf neue
Technologien setzen dass wir dafür
sorgen dass hier in Deutschland die
Technologien der Zukunft entstehen dass
hier die Jobs der Zukunft entstehen
dafür steht die deutsche
Sozialdemokratie und das wären wir in
diesem Jahr sehr sehr deutlich machen
wir sind die Partei der Industriepolitik
liebe Genossen und genossen und wir
werden dafür sorgen dass hier die
Arbeitsplätze der Zukunft entstehen das
bedeutet
[Applaus]
das bedeutet
das bedeutet hier muss investiert werden
in die modernste Infrastruktur das
bedeutet wir brauchen hier die richtigen
Rahmenbedingungen damit Industrie hier
auch wachsen kann damit Innovation
entstehen das bedeutet auch wir brauchen
und das will ich sagen Alexander von
Verdi war vorne ist er begrüßt worden
Alexanders hier wir brauchen starke
Gewerkschaften starke Betriebsräte
starke Personalräte nicht weniger ich
habe heute morgen schon wieder gehört
dass jetzt kritisiert wird dass ihr
streikt aber wo leben wir denn wir
brauchen einen starke Orientierung zu
den Gewerkschaften wir brauchen mehr
Mitbestimmung in der Industrie in allen
wirtschaftlichen Bereichen wir wissen
das Mitbestimmung ein Erfolgsgarant für
eine starke Wirtschaft ist und deswegen
gehört das für uns zu ordentliche
Industriepolitik mit dazu und ich sage
auch wir müssen endlich den Sprung nach
vorne schaffen beim Thema Fachkräfte
liebe Genossen und Genossen mike hat das
angesprochen das gilt für Frankfurt das
gilt für den Rest der Republik wenn wir
nicht endlich ist jetzt schaffen eine
ordentliche Steuerung beim Thema
Fachkräfte Zuwanderung zu haben dann
werden wir einen großen Schaden kann
auch erleiden es ist doch nicht so dass
die Menschen alle nach Deutschland
wollen die können sich mittlerweile
aussuchen die gut ausgebildeten Leute wo
die eigentlich hingehen wir müssen ja
attraktiv sein wir müssen den beste
Bedingung bieten Wohnraum Infrastruktur
Integrationsmöglichkeiten wir müssen
gucken dass den kommen und wisst ihr was
scheinheilig ist wenn der Markus Söder
diese Woche jetzt in Albanien unterwegs
ist wenn er in Rumänien unterwegs ist
und sich jetzt wieder auf den
politischen Aschermittwoch stellt da
wirkt um die Fachkräfte und heute wird
wieder ordentlich geheult gegen die
Menschen die in anderen Vornamen haben
liebe Genossen und genossen das ist
scheinheilig und damit müssen wir
endlich brechen wir brauchen eine
zuwanderungskultur hier in diesem Land
[Applaus]
wir brauchen
eine ordentliche zuwanderungskultur in
diesem Land weil das in unserem
Interesse ist in unserem Interesse und
dann ist auch total egal ob jemand
Markus oder Mehmet oder sonst wie heißt
der braucht die besten Chancen hier in
Deutschland integriert zu werden und
dann hier auch arbeiten zu können wir
können uns stolz zeigen dass so viele
Menschen nach Deutschland kommen und
hier arbeiten wollen und hier Teil auch
des Erfolgs sein wollen den wir
gemeinsam schaffen und ich finde toll
das nennt sie Faser jetzt endlich mit
Hubertus Heil dieses Schritte geht und
Eckpunkte auch für das moderne
Einwanderungsgesetz vorgelegt hat und
Nancy wird das durchbringen da bin ich
mir total sicher gegen die Konservativen
Widerstände die wieder erleben werden
aber wir müssen alle aktiv sein auch die
Wirtschaftsvertreter die hier sind die
Gewerkschaftsvertreter wir müssen aktiv
sein und dafür kämpfen dass wir das
jetzt endlich durchbekommen gegen den
Populismus der konservativen und wenn
ich schon bei Nancy bin dann lasst mich
das auch sagen ich bin total dankbar
dass Nancy die eine tolle
bundesinnenministerin ist und ich bin
mega stolz darauf was sie alles
vorantreibt du hast Hanau angesprochen
ich war selbst auch am letzten Freitag
da ich habe die
ich habe die Familien der Opfer treffen
können habe mit denen im geschützten
Rahmen einfach mal zwei Stunden geredet
das sind bewegende Geschichten und du
merkst was es bedeutet wenn du auf
einmal jemanden im
Bundesinnenministerium sitzen hat auf
dem rechten Auge nicht blind ist und
nicht weg guckt oder dann ganz klar
benennt dass das größte Problem in
diesem Land der Rechtsextremismus ist
[Applaus]
und ich bin Nancy
ich bin Nancy wahnsinnig dankbar dass
sie gesagt hat obwohl sie diesen
schweren Job als bundesinnenministerin
hat ist Hessen ihre Heimat und die Herz
ist in Hessen und sie will eure
Ministerpräsidentin werden und ich bin
mir sicher ihr kriegt mit Nancy eine
sehr sehr gute Ministerpräsidentin hier
in Hessen und sie wird das schaffen
[Applaus]
aber das
das was ich
das was ich dann an Debatten erlebt habe
um die Kandidatur von Nancy herum das
hat mich schon ein bisschen schockiert
also ich habe nie erlebt dass zum
Beispiel mein Ministerpräsident Stefan
weil dass der als als Oberbürgermeister
kandidiert hat für das
Ministerpräsidentenamt dass man den
gefragt hat ob er das beides hinkriegt
ich habe ehrlicherweise und nicht erlebt
als das Olaf Scholz als er als
Bundesfinanzminister und Vizekanzler für
den Bundeskanzler kandidiert hat dass
man den gefragt hat ob er das hinkriegt
zusammen ich weiß ja nicht ob Boris rein
gefragt wird ob er das zusammen
hinkriegt und dann erlebe ich jetzt auch
von unseren grünen Freunden dass sie ich
weiß nicht ob der Strategie ist dass sie
Habeck und Werbung jetzt auch von
kanzlerkandidaturen fernhalten wollen
weil wenn die Grünen jetzt kritisieren
das nennt sie aus dem Amt der
bundesinnenministerin als
Ministerpräsidentin kandidiert dann
legen Sie die Messlatte ja für die
nächste Kanzlerkandidatur von habe oder
Werbung auch sehr hoch
also ich will das Thema ich finde das
ist wirklich eine quatschdebatte die ich
da erlebe Nancy kann die
bundesinnenministerin sie zeigt das seit
einem Jahr dass sie dieses Amt
hervorragend ausfüllt und sie wird das
bis zum Wahltag gut machen aber dann
liebe Genossinnen und Genossen liebe
Freunde wird sie eine gute
Ministerpräsidentin Hessen sein und
dafür kämpfen wir alle zusammen
erstmalig Josef dann nennt sie Fräser
lasst uns das bitte verabreden dass das
Vorgehen ist dass wir immer
und am Ende
[Applaus]
und am Ende liebe Genossen und Genossen
lasst mich eine Sache aber noch
ansprechen die mir wirklich im Herzen
liegt und ich habe vorhin damit
angefangen dass ich gesagt habe es ist
eine wahnsinnig turbulente Phase
es sind anstrengende turbulente Zeiten
und ich will am Ende noch was sehr
ernsthaftes sagen ich bin als
Parteivorsitzender wahnsinnig viel auch
international unterwegs und wenn ich in
der Welt und in Europa unterwegs bin
dann sehe ich immer wie wahnsinnig
polarisiert andere Gesellschaften sind
wir sind auch manchmal polarisiert ich
hatte vor ein paar Tagen eine
Veranstaltung wo mir dann auch jemand
etwas Kritisches entgegen war und sagte
ja wir leben ja in Deutschland
eigentlich auch schon in einer Diktatur
ich bin hart dagegen angegangen und habe
ihm erzählt von dem Leid der Frauen im
Iran und Kabel du bist jemand der das
dankenswerter Weise auch für die
SPD-Fraktion mit
anderen organisiert dass wir als
Fraktion Patenschaften übernommen haben
für Menschen im Iran die vom Tode
bedroht sind und die verfolgt werden
dafür ein großer Dank an Dich dass Du
das organisierst
wir haben
[Applaus]
wir haben gestern alle die Geschichte
von
yamshield schamat gehört einem Deutsch
Iraner der zum Tode verurteilt wurde an
denen wir auch in diesen Zeiten wo wir
feiern und zusammenkommen und wo wir
lustig sind auch an ihn denken und dafür
kämpfen dass er nicht zu Tode verurteilt
wird wenn ich in der Welt unterwegs bin
dann sehe ich eben diese Polarisierung
die da ist und ich sehe das ist ganz
viele Länder gibt in denen in
Wahlkämpfen fast nur noch unterschieden
wird zwischen einem der für die
Demokratie steht in einem der die
Demokratie bekämpft ich war bei Lola im
August in Brasilien der Gott sei Dank
jetzt wieder Präsident geworden ist
gegen den Rechtsextremen Szenario aber
da war die Situation so wir haben das in
Frankreich gesehen macron als Kandidat
der Mitte gegen die rechtsextreme pennen
in Italien unserer Parteikollege in
rigoletta der als
Sozialdemokrat gegen eine rechtsextreme
melonie eine postfaschistin leider
verloren hat in Schweden wo ist die
Rechtsextremen mit unter Richtung der
konservativen mit einem mandatvorsprung
waren die Sozialdemokratin Magdalena
Andersen gestürzt haben bei der Wahl
was ich damit sagen will ist wir haben
in vielen Demokratien einen Zustand wo
die Polarisierung so krass ist dass du
nur noch ein Demokraten gegen einen
nichtdemokraten hast und das ist in
Deutschland anders wir hatten bei der
Bundestagswahl Laschet Werbung und
Scholz ich hatte ein Favoriten es hat
doch Gott sei Dank geklappt aber ich
würde den anderen nie absprechen dass
sie auch vernünftige Demokraten sind und
dass sie auch den Job wahrscheinlich
vernünftig ausgefüllt hätten und das ist
etwas liebe Genossen und genossen was
nicht selbstverständlich ist das ist
nicht Gott gegeben dass wir so stabil
bleiben in der Demokratie dass wir in
der Lage sind bei all dem Streit auch an
politischen Aschermittwoch und bei all
den Spitzen und bei all den politischen
Schlägen auch die man durch das mal
austeilt und das macht ja auch Spaß mehr
auch aber dass man am Ende in der Lage
ist auch in einer parlamentarischen
Wirkung Diplomatie und Demokratie ein
Konsens zu finden der das Land stark
macht und das sollten wir in einem Tag
wie heute und in einer Lage wie wir sie
gerade haben nicht vergessen wir alle
hier im Raum egal ob wir Politiker sind
auf der kommunalen eben auf der
Bundesebene ob wir
Theater besitzen was wunderschön ist ob
wir hier sind als Gewerkschaftsvertreter
als Arbeitgeber als aktive in der
Zivilgesellschaft wir alle tragen eine
Verantwortung dafür dass unser Land so
stabil bleibt und dass die Demokratie so
stabil bleibt und da will ich an einem
Tag wie heute auch daran erinnern dass
wir genau uns darauf besinnen sollten
bei allen politischen Streit wir wollen
dass Deutschland ein starkes Land bleibt
dafür haben wir 22 wichtige
Entscheidungen getroffen dafür werden
wir 23 wichtige Entscheidungen treffen
aber das Wichtige ist dass wir den
politischen Konsens in der Mitte dass
wir den auch immer wieder suchen und wir
alle gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass das ja
eine starke Demokratie bleibt liebe
Genossen und Genossen vielen Dank dass
ich heute bei Euch in Frankfurt sein
durfte lieber Mike du bist der richtige
für Frankfurt ich habe gesagt ich mich
jetzt noch eine Stunde zu und können es
war wirklich wahnsinnig beeindruckend
was du alles vorhast und das ist meine
große Bitte an euch alle
mike hat gesagt das wird ein knappes
Rennen das wird ein knappes Rennen und
ich weiß als Wahlkampfmanager von Olaf
Scholz dass du ein Wahlkampf auf den
letzten Metern entschieden wird und
deswegen ist ganz wichtig dass Sie heute
feiert und trinkt ruhig auch diese
Bierflaschen die vor euch stehen ja das
ist nicht nur in Passau so dass man Bier
trinken darf aber ab heute Mittag ab
heute Mittag macht bitte Wahlkampf seit
unterwegs auf der Arbeit im
Freundeskreis im Verein auf der Straße
die Nachbarn egal ob es das hören wollen
oder nicht sagt den hier hat sich ein
toller junger Mann mit vielen Ideen für
Frankfurt aufgemacht euer nächster
Oberbürgermeister zu werden und wir
kämpfen gemeinsam dass es wird vielen
dank vielen Dank fürs Zuhören euch alles
gut
ja das war die Rede von Lars Klingbeil
in Frankfurt das war der politische
Aschermittwoch oder ist der politische
Aschermittwoch der hessischen SPD
immerhin auch Hessen ist ja eh nicht wie
Bayern im Wahlkampf von insofern hatte
die Reden sicherlich nicht nur die
Bedeutung für die Oberbürgermeisterwahl
in Frankfurt sondern natürlich auch für
die Wahl zum hessischen Landtag und bei
mir im Studio ist noch immer
frankentdecker Politikwissenschaftler
von der Universität Bonn das war ja
jetzt eine ganz andere Rede von Lars
Klingbeil als das was wir vom
bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten zu hören
bekommen haben er hat ja auch sehr viel
ernste Themen angesprochen gab mal
zwischendurch den ein oder anderen
seitenhiebte muss er das machen als
Regierungspartei oder ist das so die Art
von Lars klingen bei jetzt im Vergleich
zu einem CSU-Chef Markus Söder also es
war eine ganz interessante Verbindung
von staatstragender Rede die eigentlich
zum politischen Aschermittwoch nicht
passt und Wahlkampfrede und deshalb auch
der Ort Frankfurt also das war viel
sinnvoller jetzt für den
SPD-Vorsitzenden nach Frankfurt zu gehen
denn dort finden jetzt die OB-Wahlen
statt und gleichzeitig finden im Land
Hessen aber auch
Landtagswahlen statt bei der bei denen
die SPD natürlich bessere Chancen hat
als in Bayern wo sie
abgeschlagen ist und die Gelegenheit
hatte natürlich genutzt denn beide
Kandidaten Mike Joseph und nennt sie
Faser sind durchaus aussichtsreich also
die Situation zu Bayern könnte nicht
unterschiedlicher sein aber wie sie
sagen er ist Mitglied der
Regierungspartei der Kanzlerpartei und
er hat im totalen Unterschied zu Söder
sich auf die großen Fragen konzentriert
die sozialökologische Transformation
oder wie er sagt Modernisierung des
Landes und den Ukraine ja doch andere
ernste Themen angesprochen wie denn Iran
oder das Erdbeben in der Türkei und hat
Söder dann natürlich auch einen
Seitenhieb verpasst weil er Söder genau
das nicht gemacht habe sondern sich mit
mit Mädchen
ein Stück weit an neben Themen
abgearbeitet hatten die keine wirkliche
Priorität haben in der Bundesrepublik
also ein ganz anderen Ton gesetzt in
einem ganz anderen Kontext spannend war
ja in diesem Zusammenhang nennt sie
fieser die hat er ja mehrfach
angesprochen die war aber nicht da die
ist ja wie wir wissen in der Türkei dort
im Krisengebiet vor Ort ist das
schlechtes Timing gewesen dass man das
jetzt nicht die Reise in die Türkei
vielleicht hätte anders planen müssen
oder war es eine Taktik das nennt sie
Feser da momentan noch aus dem Wahlkampf
rausgehalten wird nein der Wahlkampf
beginnt hier ohne hin erst die Wahl ist
im Oktober dann im Sommer und ich denke
es wäre umgekehrt ein Fehler gewesen die
Prioritäten so zu setzen dass sie jetzt
quasi schon im Vorwahl Kampf dort
auftritt anstatt sich um das zu kümmern
was sie als Bundesinnenminister
natürlich auch in einer solchen
Situation
machen muss
er hat denke ich auch sie
verteidigt mit einem Argument was in
Wirklichkeit gar nicht sticht natürlich
kann man sich aus einem Amt heraus auch
für ein anderes Amt bewerben das wird
auch die CDU in Hessen nicht kritisieren
können weil das ihre eigene Leute früher
auch gemacht haben der Punkt bei Faser
ist er dass sie gesagt hat sie würde im
Falle einer Niederlage eben nicht in
Hessen bleiben das hat sie aber vorher
angekündigt aber da liegt natürlich auch
in gewisses Risiko ihrer Kandidatur aber
die Umfragen sehen im Moment jetzt auch
nicht so schlecht aus für die SPD in
Hessen das hängt sicherlich auch damit
zusammen dass der Gegend Kandidat
Ministerpräsident Boris rein eigentlich
eher
nass geblieben ist er ist ja auch erst
seit kurzem im Amt vor allem
bundespolitisch wenig in Erscheinung
getreten ist und
deshalb war es für aus der SPD Sicht
vielleicht durchaus auch eine kluge
Entscheidung jetzt mit Faeser ein
Schwergewicht in dieser
Auseinandersetzung zu schicken was ich
immer ganz interessant finde ich habe
viele Reden von Lars Klingbeil in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten mal verfolgt
dass er eigentlich jedes Mal die Politik
des Kanzlers ein Stück weit entschuldigt
in Schutz nimmt er sagt ja mal die
besondere Art des Kanzlers er ist froh
dass er so ein besonderer Kanzleramt ist
das könnte man auch ein bisschen anders
interpretieren das Zaubern das Kanzlers
was ja von anderen Parteien auch von den
ampelkoalitionsparteien der FDP und
Grünen häufig kritisiert wird und
natürlich auch von der Opposition CDU
CSU das ist so ein bisschen seine
Entschuldigung oder sehen Sie das anders
würden sie das anders einordnen also ich
würde das nicht als Entschuldigung
bezeichnen sondern das ist
ein werben für einen aus seiner Sicht
aber durchaus aus der Sicht eines doch
erheblichen Teils auch der Bevölkerung
vernünftigen
mittelwegs der sich nicht beirren lässt
auf der einen Seite von Forderungen
immer mehr und immer schneller
Waffen zu liefern der auf der anderen
Seite aber auch diesen
Führungsanspruch den man ja angemahnt
hat den deutschen Führungsanspruch auch
in diesen Fragen in Europa dann faktisch
einlöst und ich glaube
dass die SPD obwohl sich das jetzt in
den Umfragen gar nicht so sehr
niederschlägt damit schon punkten kann
und wir haben das ja auch gesehen in
Passau dass Söder die Grünen kritisiert
hat die Außenministerin für ihre zu
forsche Politik also er hat ihn direkt
möglich auch dieses klingenpeitsche
Argument dass wir bei Olaf Scholz ganz
gut aufgehoben sind dass der kühlen Kopf
bewahrt indirekt damit selber bestätigt
und Scholz für diese Politik überhaupt
nicht kritisiert sagen Sie mir zwei
Stichworte gegeben die Grünen und Passau
da wollen wir nämlich jetzt gleich als
nächstes mal hingehen Professor Decker
erstmal bis hier weit vielen Dank aber
wir schauen uns natürlich auch noch die
anderen reden zum politischen
Aschermittwoch an und da sind wir
nämlich als nächstes bei den Grünen die
ebenso wie die CSU in Passau sich
getroffen haben und sich auch zur Stunde
vermutlich noch treffen und die
Parteivorsitzende Ricarda lang sie hat
dort sich an ihre Parteifreundin und
Freunde gewandt
ich wurde vor ziemlich genau ein Jahr
zur Parteivorsitzenden von Bündnis 90
die Grünen gewählt und ich habe mir vor
kurzem mal meine Bewerbungsrede
angeschaut die ich aus meinem Wohnzimmer
gehalten habe weil ich wegen Corona gar
nicht zum Parteitag durfte und ich habe
dort Dinge gesagt wie nach 16 Jahren in
der Opposition da können wir endlich all
das umsetzen was wir immer nur gefordert
haben und ganz ehrlich an ganz vielen
Stellen da haben wir auch genau das
getan im Turbo beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien und mit der
Abschaffung des Paragrafen 219a am
informationsverbot für schlafabbrüche
aber wir haben ein ganz vielen Stellen
auch ganz andere Dinge getan
ehrlich gesagt Dinge die ich mir niemals
hätte vorstellen können Dinge die für
mich nicht vorstellbar waren dass wir
diese Entscheidung mal treffen müssen
und ich glaube gerade deshalb ist es gut
dass wir Moment dort sind wo wir sind
gerade deshalb ist es gut dass wir
Verantwortung übernehmen weil wir uns
nicht wegducken weil wir auch bereit
sind über unseren eigenen Schatten zu
springen und weil man Politik eben nicht
für die Realität macht die man sich
gewünscht hat sondern für die Realität
die da ist
und ich möchte dafür ein Beispiel nennen
und ich weiß dass es eigentlich
überhaupt nicht zum Aschermittwoch passt
zu lustigen Witzen und zum draufhauen
aber ich finde ehrlich gesagt gerade in
der Woche wie diesen in der Woche von 24
Februar kann ich es nicht ungesagt
lassen denn an diesen 24 februar vor
einem Jahr wo die Welt gerade für viele
meiner Generationen den friedlichen
Europa aufgewachsen sind auf den Kopf
gestellt durch diesen
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg von
Vladimir Putin und ich hatte in diesem
Jahr oft schlaflose Nächte ich hatte oft
Nächte wo ich überlegt habe machen wir
es richtige was ist denn eigentlich das
richtige in zu einer Zeit was bedeutet
es denn Friedenspartei zu sein wenn ein
Land auf diese Art und Weise angegriffen
wird
und für mich gab es immer wieder einen
Satz der mir in der Zeit viel
Orientierung gegeben hat und das ist der
erste Satz unseres Grundsatzprogrammes
dort steht im Zentrum der Politik steht
der Mensch in seiner Würde und Freiheit
und das bedeutet es denn die Würde des
Menschen zu verteidigen wenn ich die
Menschen zu unterstützen deren würde
gerade von Kriegsverbrechern massenweise
dem Erdboden gleichgemacht werden soll
das bedeutet es eine Friedenspartei zu
sein auch eine Freiheitspartei wenn ich
auf der Seite derer zu stehen die die
internationale Friedensordnung
verteidigen und jetzt gibt es andere
Stimmen es gibt sie teilweise hier vor
der Tür es gibt sie jetzt mit einem
Aufruf von Zara Wagenknecht und alle
schwarze die sagen Frieden das heißt für
uns die Ukraine muss jetzt mal nachgeben
die Ukraine die sollte jetzt eigentlich
aufgeben
aber ich frag mich was ist das denn für
ein friedene wo Menschen in besetzten
Gebieten leben wo in ihre Sprache
verboten wird wo die rekultur verboten
wird wo sie verdauern Angst vor Terror
und Gewalt Leben und was wäre das für
ein friedene wo ein Kriegsverbrecher
durchkommt mit einem
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg wir
müssen darüber diskutieren was der
richtige Weg ist was die richtigen
Schritte sind wir müssen auf diskutieren
aber was nicht geht ist
Opfer und Täter einfach zu vertauschen
denn eines ist klar
eines ist klar wenn die Ukraine die
Waffen niederlegt dann endet die Ukraine
wenn Russland die Waffen niederlegt dann
endet dieser Krieg und deshalb
unterstützen wir die Ukraine weil wir
wollen dass dieser Krieg endet und
deshalb unterstützen wir die Ukraine
weil wir Frieden wollen
aber wir müssen auch ehrlich sein
schuldig an diesen Krieg ist einer und
der ist Wladimir Putin aber die Art und
Weise wie hart diese Krieg auch uns hier
in Deutschland getroffen hat das ist
nicht vom Himmel gefallen das ist kein
Zufall sondern das ist die Folge von
politischen Entscheidungen denn warum
sind wir denn so verdammt abhängig von
russischen Gas weil noch im
Bundestagswahlkampf ausgelacht wurde
wenn sie darauf hingewiesen hat dass
North Stream 2 kein
privatwirtschaftliches Unterfangen
sondern fossiler Spaltpilz Europa ist
warum werden Solarpanels in China gebaut
und nicht hier in Bayern weil Peter
Altmaier eine florierende Industrie
abgewürgt hat und es so Zehntausende von
Arbeitsplätzen verloren haben warum es
ist immer noch
für viele Leute so verdammt schwer
gerade ihre gasrechen zu bezahlen gerade
Ihre Heizung weil wärmewende gerne als
so ein grünes Nischenthema für die
Spinne abgetan wurde und warum waren zu
Strom im letzten Jahr zu verdammt teuer
unter anderem weil wir sehr viel Strom
nach Frankreich exportiert haben weil
dort die hat schon Kraftwerke vom Netz
genommen werden mussten weil sie eben
nicht sicher waren und deshalb ist für
mich eines in dieser Zeit klar ich will
nie wieder hören dass wir Moment das
Scheitern von grüner Energiepolitik
erleben das genaue Gegenteil ist der
Fall wir haben im letzten Jahr das
fulminante Scheitern der fossilen
Politik der großen Koalition erlebt
und jetzt
jetzt gehen wir voran und wir machen es
anders mit der Ampel mit den Grünen der
Regierung allen voran mit Robert Habeck
und ich kann euch sagen manchmal fühlt
es sich so ein bisschen an als hätte man
eh schon eine steile Bergwand man hat er
doch einen Rucksack voller Steine drauf
die letzten 16 Jahre man geht da hoch
und mittendrin fängt an zu regnen und
die Krise kommt und in dieser Zeit haben
wir alles gegeben um dieses Land gut
durch die Krise zu bringen und
gleichzeitig uns von Diktatoren ab
unabhängig zu machen um die
energieversorgen zu sichern und
gleichzeitig dieses Land endlich zu
modernisieren und wir haben ja im Bund
viel Erfahrung mit Oppositionen 16 Jahre
lang Erfahrung und Opposition ist
wichtig dafür muss auch mal drauf haben
Opposition muss kritisieren das ist
nicht nur okay das ist sogar verdammt
notwendig in der Demokratie aber ganz
ehrlich ich Freunde wenn diejenigen die
uns das 16 Jahre lang eingebrockt haben
wenn ich ein Karren in die Scheiße
geritten habe und dann andere den für
mich rauszieht dann habe ich doch eine
Entscheidung ob ich entweder meckernd am
Rand stehe und noch mehr reinstoße oder
ob ich endlich auch selbst Teil der
Lösung wäre indem jedes Land
effizienzgesetz hat in dem hier in
Bayern man freiwillig auf die 10 Tage
sind verzichtet hätte und in dem Süden
Deutschland hier in Bayern endlich die
Stromnetze ausgebaut werden das wäre
staatspolitische Verantwortung für die
CSU und die Union
und was erleben wir stattdessen
wir erleben das während wir hier über
Energieversorgung und Gerechtigkeit
sprechen Markus Schröder wahrscheinlich
gerade Momenten Passau gestern auch
schon auf Twitter über den Zwang zum
Gendern die Politiker correctness und
die cancel culture redet ganz ehrlich
Verantwortung das kommt ja auch daher
Antworten zu geben und verantworten auf
reale Probleme und nicht Probleme zu
finden denn während wir hier über die
Probleme der Menschen sprechen wird dort
gerade
Kulturkampf Theater auf größte Bühne
aufgeführt aber lieber Herr Söder ich
kann Ihnen eines versprechen es ist mir
komplett egal wie sie reden aber was wir
nicht egal ist ist wenn ein
Ministerpräsident zum Beispiel ein
Verbrennermotor seine politischen
Positionen wechselt wie andere ihre
Unterhosen und so Vertrauen in Politik
verspielt was mir nicht egal ist ist das
hier in den letzten Jahren der Ausbau
der Windkraft für schlafen wurde und nur
das Potenzial von Bayern nicht genutzt
wurde was mir nicht egal ist ist das so
Markus Söder den Wohlstand Bayerns und
damit auch den Wohlstand Deutschlands
gefährdet und deshalb in Richtung der
Union es ist Zeit für weniger
Identitätspolitik und mehr Verantwortung
für Bayern
und wir wissen aber auch der Wohlstand
hier und zum Land der wurde aufgebaut
und er wird vor allem nur gesichert von
Menschen die vielleicht Eltern haben die
woanders geboren haben von Menschen die
vielleicht selbst woanders geboren
wurden und die hierher kommen um sich
einzubringen wir brauchen doch gerade in
eine alten Gesellschaft brauchen wir
fachkräfteeinwanderung das ist klar und
es ist nicht erst seit gestern so
Deutschland ist nicht erst seit gestern
Einwanderungsland sondern Menschen aus
der Gastarbeiter Generation die haben
dieses Land mit aufgebaut und das heißt
wenn Deutschland Einwanderungsland ist
dann wird es doch Zeit dass wir uns
endlich auch so verhalten dass wir
Einwanderung gestalten statt sie
abzuwehren aber wer das nicht tut
sondern wer wie Friedrich Merz in der
Zeit wo klar die Kloster ist wurde jede
IHK und jeder Unternehmer auf dem Land
sagt Frau lang wir brauchen Menschen
während dieser Zeit immer noch von
sozialtourismus und kleinen Pascha
spricht der muss sich ehrlich gesagt
nicht wundern wenn in Zukunft zwar
vielleicht noch Oppositionsführer ist
aber auch Vorsitzender von der Partei
die mit Wirtschaftskompetenz genauso
viel zu tun hat wie Ausländer hast mit
Christlichkeit
und bei all diesen Angriffen bei all
diesen Angriffen dürfen wir aber nicht
aus dem Blick verlieren das ist ganz
viel anderes gibt hier in unserem Land
das in den letzten Wochen
tausende von Menschen Spenden gesammelt
haben für Erdbebenopfer in der Türkei in
Syrien und den kurdischen Gebieten da
dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass tausende
abertausende Menschen ihre Türen
geöffnet haben für Menschen aus der
Ukraine und da dürfen wir nicht
vergessen dass unsere Kommunen trotz
schwierigste Bedingungen und wir sehen
wie schwierig diese Bedingungen sind
gerade unfassbares leisten um die
Menschen hier willkommen zu heißen oder
dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen dass
ehrlich gesagt in unseren Schulen in so
einem fuhren und sondern Universitäten
schon längst Menschen zusammen leben
haben egal ob ihre Eltern aus Ankara
oder aus Augsburg kommen und dass diese
Menschen zum Glück stolz darauf sind
dass sie in einem Land leben wo die
Frage ob man dazugehört nicht davon
abhängt ob man Katha Ludwig Ricarda oder
Cem heißt
ich hatte dieses Jahr die große Ehre
dass ich in Ägypten dabei sein durfte
bei den Klimaverhandlungen in Sharm el
Sheikh die internationale Kopf ich habe
dort Menschen getroffen aus Bangladesch
Menschen die teilweise ihre Verwandten
eine ihre Schwester bei
Hochwasserkatastrophen verloren hatte
und dem Moment ist mir noch mal ziemlich
klar geworden das eigentlich wenn wir
immer von Klimaschutz sprechen das ein
bisschen das falsche Wort ist denn das
Klima braucht uns eigentlich nicht das
ist nicht auf uns angewiesen wenn wir
über Klimaschutz sprechen dann sprechen
wir über nichts anderes als darüber dass
wir unsere Kinder schützen dass wir
unsere Großeltern schützen dass wir
unsere Liebsten und unsere Freundinnen
schützen Klimaschutz ist am Ende nichts
anderes als menschheitsschutz und es ist
klar bei der menschheitsschutz da muss
jeder sein Beitrag leisten da muss jeder
Verantwortung übernehmen und das gilt
verdammt noch mal auch für den
Verkehrsbereich da reicht es nicht zu
sagen wir bauen neue Autobahnen sondern
da muss endlich ernst gemacht werden
und sagt da gibt's gar nicht nur den
einen Weg wenn ich sage ich mal
Ordnungsrecht nicht so gerne mag dann
muss ich richtig gelten die Hand nehmen
und investieren in die Schiene wenn ich
eher Geld sparen will damit die
Schuldenbremse sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
wichtig ist dann brauche ich klares
Ordnungsrecht aber was nicht geht ist zu
allem davon immer nur nein zu sagen denn
wenn wir es ernst meinen Pariser Klima
kommen dann können wir uns nein sagen
Ministerien schlichtweg nicht mehr
leisten dann brauchen wir eine Politik
die ja sagt ja zu mehr
Regionalisierungsmitteln und mehr
Mobilität auf dem Land ja zum Abbau von
umweltschädlichen Subventionen wie den
Dienstwagen Privileg und wenn ihr mich
fragt auch endlich ja zu einem
Tempolimit auf deutschen Autobahnen
Ricarda lang war das co-parteichef in
der grünen an dieser Stelle auch von mir
noch mal einen schönen guten Tag wir
haben gewechselt die Crew allerdings
wäre noch da ist ist Frank Decker den
ich herzlich begrüßte Politologe der
Universität in Bonn Herr Decker die
Grünen in Bayern liegen auf dem zweiten
Platz 17,2% laut aktuellen Umfragen vom
19 Februar allerdings werden sie
wahrscheinlich nicht mitregieren mit der
CSU zumindest nicht anders wenn die die
Wahl gewinnen sollte im Herbst ja wir
haben eigentlich hier auch ein Effekt
den man immer beobachtet
die Partei die im Bund in der Opposition
ist kann bei Landtagswahlen profitieren
die CSU hatte ja bei der letzten Wahl
2018 mit 37% ihr historisch schlechtes
Ergebnis jetzt liegt sie wieder bei 40
und mehr Prozent in den Umfragen und von
daher könnte es wirklich so sein dass
die Grünen dann nicht benötigt werden
als Koalitionspartner das ist nach wie
vor reicht für eine Mehrheit zusammen
mit den Freien Wählern und die Freien
Wähler stehen der CSU auch in den
Inhalten näher als die Grünen ja auf
jeden Fall die Freien Wähler sind in
gewisser Weise Fleisch vom Fleisch der
CSU also das ist dann eine
ergänzungskoalition und man hat ja bei
der Söder Rede gesehen hat die Freien
Wähler total
geschont und hat sich vor allem an den
Grünen abgearbeitet ja dann schauen wir
mal auf die Grünen im Bund auch Ricarda
lang die koopertal-chefin hat ja hier
das war jetzt nicht die komplette Rede
aber es waren Ausschnitte zumindest
Themen angesprochen die den Bund
betreffen das Land betreffen die Grünen
im Bund sorgen sich offenbar das
herzensprojekte ihre herzensprojekte
finanziell nicht umgesetzt werden können
es gab da einen etwas seltsam anmutenden
Briefwechsel zwischen
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck und dem
Finanzminister Christian Lindner von der
FDP schon ein ungewöhnlicher Ton
angeschlagen wurde man hat sich gesiezt
und der Streit ging darum dass man doch
mehr Finanzen zur Verfügung stellen
sollte statt nur auf die Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse zu achten oder ja von der
Euphorie des Anfangs ist eigentlich
nichts mehr übrig geblieben die
Ampelkoalition ist genauso eine
streit-koalition wie es die großen
Koalitionen gewesen sind wo sich also
Parteien aus verschiedenen politischen
Lagern gezwungenermaßen miteinander
verbinden es gab ja am Anfang so die
Hoffnung dass auch von den beiden
Parteien selber geführt von den Grünen
und der FDP dass sie die Motoren sein
würden der Modernisierung dass sie quasi
die SPD antreiben würden das hat sich
aber in dieser Form nicht bereit ganz im
Gegenteil sie blockieren sich an vielen
Stellen eben in dieser Koalition
gegenseitig schielen einseitig auch auf
ihre jeweiligen Wähler klientelen
die Stadt das ganze bisschen stärker
im Auge zu behalten und auch das was man
ja erreicht hat in dieser Koalition
vielleicht auch bisschen selbstbewusster
in den Vordergrund zu stellen die Bürger
schätzen es nicht wenn Regierungen
untereinander zerstritten sind jetzt war
eine weitere Meldung oder was beobachten
konnten dass ich innerhalb der Grünen
eine Gruppe gebildet hat die sogenannten
Wert reallos kann man jetzt von
französisch-wert Grün ableiten
phonetisch hört es sich so ein bisschen
nach der werteunion der CDU an und geht
auch in die Richtung also eher ein eher
konservativer Kreis innerhalb der Grünen
die unzufrieden sind mit der
Migrationspolitik ja man muss sehen die
Grünen sind ja längst keine Dame ohne
Unterleib mehr das heißt sie sind auch
mittlerweile auf der kommunalen Ebene
immer stärker verankert stellen auch in
Städten die Oberbürgermeister und sind
natürlich dann auch mit der Realität der
Probleme ganz unmittelbar konfrontiert
aber ich glaube dass das eine
minderheitsströmung ist übrigens genauso
wie die radikalen klimapolitiker wir
haben das auch bei der Wahl in Berlin
gesehen da ist nicht viel weggegangen
von grünen
Wählerpotenzial aber das bringt
natürlich auch Unruhe in die Grüne
Partei und die
diese Gruppierung hat ja durchaus einen
Punkt wenn sie auch die eigene Partei
mahnt eben über solche Themen zu
sprechen man hat ja in Berlin gesehen
dass das auch Regierungen nichts nützt
wenn sie das nicht mit hinreichender
Ernsthaftigkeit betrachten ja und die
Kommunen die eben doch echt sind unter
den der Menge an an geflüchteten
Menschen die sie gerade versorgen und
eben beklagen dass es eben zu wenig und
finanzielle Unterstützung gibt vom Bund
wird gerne noch auf einen Punkt kommen
wenn wir über die Grünen reden dieses
Jahr müssen wir natürlich auch überall
sprechen
im Nachgang wie bewerten sie das ist das
eine Art Trauma für die Grünen sozusagen
das Hartz IV der Grünen nein ich habe es
ja eben schon gesagt
Hartz IV hat ja letztlich zur Entstehung
einer gesamtdeutschen Linkspartei
geführt dass sehe ich eigentlich bei den
Grünen nicht aber in der Partei gibt es
natürlich auch unterschiedliche
Positionen und in der Regierung müssen
ohnehin Kompromisse gemacht werden also
von daher haben es Regierungsparteien
immer schwer aber
die Grünen Wähler sind ja in vielerlei
Hinsicht auch pragmatischer was viele
Fragen betrifft ich nenne nun aber das
Beispiel Atomkraft als die eigenen
Mitglieder oder die Funktionäre der
Partei und diese sozial ökologische
Transformation ist natürlich etwas was
die Menschen auch nicht überfordern darf
also man sieht z.B das etwa das von
grünen versprochene Klima Geld also
womit ja auch ein sozialer Ausgleich
geschaffen werden soll dass das
überhaupt nicht wirklich energisch
verfolgt wird und ich glaube da drohen
den Grünen wahrscheinlich sogar größere
Probleme als jetzt von diesen doch
radikalen Gruppierungen sei es jetzt
diese migrationskritische Gruppierung
oder die diejenigen die für radikalere
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen eintreten zum
Beispiel oder die radikaleren
klimaaktivisten der Grünen danke Herr
Decker für den Moment wir schauen weiter
zur nächsten Partei zum nächsten
politischen Mittwoch und zwar zur FDP
die hält ihren politischen Mittwoch in
Dingolfing an und Christian Lindner
fdparteichef hat dort gesprochen
es werden derbe Reden gehalten
insbesondere bei der CSU gerade schon
auf den
Nachrichtenagenturen gelesen ein
bisschen so wie immer zu Beginn eines
Landtagswahlkampfs hat das Bier mehr
Prozent als die Umfrageergebnisse der
FDP
aber auch das kennen wir FDP ist eben
wenn du das Abenteuer suchst
und lieber Martin
lieber Martin das werden wir demnächst
noch ändern am Ende wird es umgekehrt
sein FDP mehr Prozent als das Starkbier
das am Wahlabend ausgeschenkt wird
Liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde also es ist ein
bisschen wie immer am politischen
Aschermittwoch aber gerade wenn ich in
diesen Zeiten sehe was der bayerische
Ministerpräsident und auch einiger
andere
sagen ich habe das Gefühl diese Art von
Derbheit ist eigentlich etwas aus der
Zeit gefallen
und deshalb glaube ich für uns Freie
Demokraten wie wir das bei Nicole und
bei Martin gesehen haben für uns Freie
Demokraten empfiehlt sich eigentlich
etwas anderes mag die CSU sich am
politischen Mitbewerber abarbeiten wir
als Freie Demokraten wir arbeiten uns
vor allen Dingen an den Problemen der
Menschen in diesem Land ab das ist eben
der Unterschied zwischen uns und denen
das ist der Unterschied zwischen uns und
denen das ist das was uns als Freie
Demokraten als eine liberale Partei
ausmacht auch an einem solchen Tag kann
man ja durchaus auch Respekt sollen
ich muss jetzt zwei Parteien außen vor
lassen aber im demokratischen Zentrum
unseres politischen Systems da verdienen
doch auch unsere Mitbewerberinnen und
Mitbewerber Respekt es ist doch gut dass
es in Deutschland eine Sozialdemokratie
gibt die vor allen Dingen den sozialen
Ausgleich ins Zentrum ihrer Politik
stellt es ist doch gut das ist eine
grüne Partei gibt die eine besondere
Sensibilität für ökologische
Fragestellungen hat doch gut das ist
eine Christdemokratie gibt die den
Konservativismus in unserem Land
geprägt hat die sich auf die katholische
Soziallehre bezieht und auch mit uns
gemeinsam über viele Jahrzehnte für die
soziale Marktwirtschaft gestritten das
ist doch gut dass es solche politische
Mitbewerber gibt
muss ich preislich auch noch was
Positives über die CSU sagen
also
vielleicht dies vielleicht dies die die
CSU ist ist die die Synthese genau das
kann man vielleicht sagen die CSU ist
die Synthese
Laptop und Lederhose und Markus Söder
hat diese Kraft der CSU eine Synthese zu
machen die hat er sogar noch mit seinem
Talent auf die auf die absolute Spitze
getrieben im einen Arm das Ferkel
im anderen Arm der Teller mit dem
Kotelett auf der einen Seite den Baum
umarmen
auf der einen auf der einen Seite den
Baum umarmen und gleichzeitig die
Motorsäge im Kopf haben
streiten für das Kopftuchverbot und
gleichzeitig für die maskenpflicht die
CSU das ist die Partei für Leute denen
eine Meinung nicht genügt sondern die
alle Meinungen wollen und das Gegenteil
davon
und liebe Freundinnen und Freunde das
verdient Respekt diese
Integrationsleistung
so wie wir Respekt anderen zollen wollen
wir freilich auch das unser Respekt
gezahlt wird denn so gut es ist das ist
eine Partei für den sozialen Ausgleich
gibt so wichtig ist dass es eine Partei
gibt für ökologische Sensibilität zur
notwendig es ist dass es auch eine
konservative Strömung in unserem Land
gibt
unverzichtbar ist auch eine liberale
Kraft die den einzelnen Menschen und
sein Recht auf Selbstbestimmung ins
Zentrum stellt auch sie verdient Respekt
denn das ist der Unterschied eben
zwischen uns und der CSU für die CSU
gilt
Freiheit von Überzeugung und für uns
gilt Freiheit als Überzeugung das ist
der Unterschied
und
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde vielleicht
hat man das
nirgendwo und niemals so deutlich
gesehen wie während der Pandemie für
viele von uns hat schon eine vollendete
Vergangenheit
und es ist eine menschliche Eigenschaft
und vielleicht auch nicht die
schlechteste wir sind in der Lage zu
vergessen und auch zu verzeihen
wir sollten es aber nicht zu schnell tun
in der Politik
denn während der corona-pandemie ist
eine Charakterfrage gestellt worden
ohne Frage das war eine gefährliche und
ist eine gefährliche Erkrankung die
Freien Demokraten weder im Deutschen
Bundestag noch im maximal milliarium wir
haben niemals die corona-pandemie auf
die leichte Schulter genommen oder ihre
Gefahr die Risiken geläutet das haben
wir zu keinem Fall getan aber wir haben
eben immer im Blick behalten dass der
Gesundheitsschutz selbst auch
soziale Kosten hat wenn beispielsweise
die Schulen geschlossen werden und
Kinder und Jugendliche keinen Zugang
mehr zu Bildung haben wenn Menschen
nicht in der Lage sind ihre Freunde ihre
Familie zu treffen und in der kleinen
Wohnung drohen zu vereinsamen das war
eine Charakterfrage für unsere
Gesellschaft angesichts einer Bedrohung
wie hältst du es mit den bürgerlichen
Freiheitsrechten die in unserem
Grundgesetz garantiert sind
wir haben nie die Gefahren geleugnet
aber wir haben immer an die
Verhältnismäßigkeit appelliert in der
bayerischen Staatskanzlei in dessen saß
ein Ministerpräsident der
aus dem starken Auftritt als
Landesvaters während der Pandemie
politisches Kapital schlagen wollte dem
waren während der Pandemie die
bürgerlichen Freiheitsrechte egal weil
er lieber auf den starken Staat gesetzt
hat er wollte dass die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger begründen warum sie auch während
der Pandemie Eigenverantwortung im
Gesundheitsbereich leben können das war
die Beweislastumkehr und niemals wieder
darf sich eine Situation wie diese
wiederholen denn immer muss der Staat
denn
denn immer liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
denn immer muss der Staat müssen
Regierungen und Parlamente begründen
warum sie und wie lange sie in unsere
Freiheiten Eingreifen niemals dürfen es
die stolzen Bürgerinnen und Bürger sein
die sich rechtfertigen müssen wenn sie
auf ihren Freiheiten bestehen das darf
sich nie wiederholen
und liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde das werde
ich nicht nur am Aschermittwoch in
Erinnerung rufen sondern an jedem Tag in
jeder Woche in den ganzen Monaten bis
zur Landtagswahl müssen wir an diesen
politischen Charaktertest im Freistaat
Bayern erinnern hätte es die Freien
Demokraten im Maximilianeum nicht
gegeben die mit einer
verantwortungsbewussten aber eben auch
grundrechtsorientierten pandemie-politik
eine wahre Alternative geboten hätten
ich glaube dann wäre die pandemiepolitik
noch anders angelegt worden als sie
ohnehin schon das gesellschaftliche
Leben eingeschränkt hat
meine Damen und Herren
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
einen Angriff auf die Freiheit ganz
andere Art bezeugen wir alle jeden Tag
seit fast einem Jahr nämlich aufgrund
des schrecklichen Angriffs in der
schrecklichen russischen Angriffs auf
die Ukraine und heute ist eigentlich ein
ja gelöster das war ein ausgelassener
Tag aber wir dürfen nicht verkennen dass
in unserer unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft
wenige Flugstunden entfernt ein
tödlicher Krieg passiert nach einem
Angriff von Putin auf die Ukraine seit
einem Jahr sterben dort Menschen
und die Bilder berühren uns alle aber
mich beeindruckt auch die unglaubliche
Tapferkeit mit der die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer für ihre Freiheit kämpfen wir
dürfen nie vergessen warum die Ukraine
angegriffen worden ist sie wurde
angegriffen weil sie so leben wollen wie
wir in Freiheit weil sie sich
entschieden haben gegen eine Zukunft als
Satellit von Russland von Putins Gnaden
weil sie sich gegen seinen Oligarchen
Kapitalismus entschieden haben und für
unsere freiheitliche Wirtschaftsordnung
weil sie nicht in einer autoritären
geschlossenen Gesellschaft leben wollten
mit Zensuren und verboten sondern in
einer Gesellschaft der
Meinungspluralität die wir sie haben
deshalb ist die Ukraine angegriffen
worden dort geht es um die
Selbstbestimmung dieses Landes auf ihrem
Weg auf dem Weg der Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine in Ihre Zukunft aber dort wird
auch die friedens- und freiheitsordnung
des
jahrhunderts erstritten deshalb gehören
wir an die Seite der Ukraine und wenn
heute
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
wenn heute wenn heute ausgerechnet die
Vorsitzende der Linkspartei
diplomatische Lösungen fordert als wäre
es die Ukraine gewesen die Russland
angegriffen hätte und nicht Russlands
dass die Ukraine überfallen hätte
ausgerechnet an diesem Tag fordert
ausgerechnet die Vorsitzende der
Linkspartei eine diplomatische Lösung
das zeigt aus auch ihrer eigenen
Geschichte hat die Linkspartei nichts
gelernt sie steht schon wieder auf der
falschen Seite der Geschichte
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
dieser Krieg in der Ukraine hat auch
Auswirkungen auf uns er hat auch unsere
eigenen Defizite noch einmal vor Augen
geführt
insbesondere mit Blick auf die
Bundeswehr und unsere Möglichkeiten
andere zu unterstützen zu ertüchtigen
aber es ist auch ein Schlaglicht auf
unsere Fähigkeit zur Landes- und
bündnisverteidigung selbst dass wir seit
einigen Monaten beobachten können der
Inspekteur des Heeres hat
wir erinnern uns vor einigen Monaten
gesagt die Bundeswehr sei blank
und das war ein Weckruf
wir sind nicht in der Verfassung in der
wir sein müssten um den Auftrag zu
erfüllen
unser Verteidigungsbündnis und auch
unser Land zu erwehren möglicher
Angriffe von außen wir sind nicht in der
Lage andere so zu ertüchtigen mit
Ausrüstung wie wir das selber wollten
wie es unser ethischer Anspruch ist
heute sagt
Markus Söder
beim Aschermittwoch der CSU
das ist ja beklagenswert sei
wie es bei der Bundeswehr vorangehen und
der übt Kritik an diesem Sonderprogramm
dem sogenannten Sondervermögen das heißt
es in der Haushaltsordnung kann Carsten
klein bestätigen dass wir eingerichtet
hätten und bei aller Notwendigkeit die
Beschaffungsprozesse der Bundeswehr zu
optimieren schneller zu machen und auch
mir gehen die Fortschritte noch nicht
weit genug wir werden in den nächsten
Jahren noch länger damit zu tun haben
die Bundeswehr zu ersichtigen ist es
eigentlich wirklich die die Aufgabe von
Markus Söder jetzt jetzt die
Bundesregierung in ausgerechnet der
Frage auch zu kritisieren vergessen wir
doch nicht es war ein
Verteidigungsminister der CSU
der die Wehrpflicht ohne Konzept
abgeschafft hat nicht aus
sicherheitspolitischen Erwägungen
sondern weil er geldeinsparen wollte es
waren doch von CDU und CSU geführte
Bundesregierungen die uns jetzt die
Bundeswehr in diesem Zustand übergeben
haben und dann kritisiert Markus Söder
uns in Wahrheit kritisiert er uns dafür
dass wir nicht schnell genug dabei sind
den Scherbenhaufen aufzukehren denn die
CSU und hinterlassen hat liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde
das doch die Bronzer
dann sagt
dann kritisiert Markus Söder das
Instrument dieses
Sonderprogramms Sondervermögens notabene
cdu/csu im Bundestag und Bundesrat haben
dem zugestimmt jetzt kritisiert er das
und sage sind so viele Schulden und ich
würde so viele Schulden machen ja sicher
ich mache nicht leichtfertig 100
Milliarden Euro Schulden aber ich sage
Ihnen und Euch auch eines
es geht ja nicht nur darum
dass Schulden begrenzt werden müssen und
wollen sondern es geht ja auch darum
wofür man das Geld einsetzt und wir
kehren zur Schuldenbremse zurück wir
müssen bitte Haushaltskonsolidierung
auch ehrgeizig sein aber von den 100
Milliarden Euro
Investitionen in unsere Sicherheit da
werde ich auf den Marktplätzen im
Freistaat Bayern jeden einzelnen Euro
verteidigen weil sie im Interesse dieses
Landes stehen auch gegenüber der CSU
und dann
vergleicht wegen eben dieser Schulden
zum Beispiel für das Sonderprogramm für
die bundeswehrvergleich Markus Söder
mich heute mit
Jannis farukes
also er Söder haben nie geglaubt dass
die FDP einmal
in die Nähe der griechischen Kommunisten
kommen würde
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde ich glaube
mit dieser aschermittwochsformulierung
sagt Markus Söder mehr über sich als
über die FDP oder mich
wenn Markus Söder mich bei den Finanzen
mit farukakis vergleichen dann zeigte er
dass er bei der Wahrheit der Trump der
deutschen Politik ist
ein berühmter bayerischer
Ministerpräsident würde jetzt an die
Medien sagen das dürfen Sie alles senden
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
martin hat es angesprochen
infolge des Ukraine Kriegs des
russischen Angriffs ist unser Land auch
wirtschaftlich unter einem großen Druck
geraten insbesondere wegen der
Energiepolitik es zeigt sich die fatale
Abhängigkeit von Energieimporten aus
Russland vor der übrigens wir als Freie
Demokraten regelmäßig gewarnt haben die
flüssiggast Terminals die jetzt gebaut
worden sind und gebaut werden die haben
wir im Deutschen Bundestag schon zu
früheren Zeiten Klaus breilnik schon zu
früheren Zeiten selbst als du im
Bundestag warst haben wir die schon
gefordert also es ist keine ganz neue
Erkenntnis ich will nicht zu nahe treten
haben wir die schon gefordert
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde jetzt sind
wir in dieser Situation der Abhängigkeit
gewesen und Putin hat unsere
Abhängigkeit nutzen wollen um einen
energiekrieg vom Zaun zu brechen der
Preis ist gestiegen und dahinter war
doch ein Kalkül bei Putin der hat
geglaubt wenn die Energiepreise wenn die
Gaspreise steigen dann wird man doch mal
sehen ob die liberalen Demokratien die
ja immer wieder gegenüber ihrer
Öffentlichkeit begründen müssen welchen
politischen Weg Sie gehen ob die
liberalen Demokratien denn dann an der
Seite der Ukraine weiter stehen würden
oder ob am Ende der eigene Wohlstand die
eigene wirtschaftliche Stärke wichtiger
ist als die liberalen Werte unserer
gesellschaftschaften hier haben wir uns
ein gutes Zeugnis ausgestellt denn trotz
aller wirtschaftlichen Schwierigkeiten
die wir gesehen haben standen und stehen
wir zu den Werten für die die Ukraine
kämpft und die uns heilig sind ist ein
gutes Zeugnis dass wir ganz ausgestellt
haben denn wie wäre es anders
Wohlstand der infrage gestellt wird ist
fraglos für unser Land eine
Herausforderung aber wir können uns
neuen Wohlstand erarbeiten mit
Unternehmergeist und Einfallsreichtum
und Leistungsbereitschaft aber umgekehrt
ein Wohlstand von Putins Gnaden für den
wir unsere Liberalen Überzeugungen
Opfern ein solcher Wohlstand wäre in
Wahrheit wertlos liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde und deshalb sind wir diesen Weg
nicht gegangen
aber
aber wir haben unsere wirtschaftliche
Substanz geschützt es kam eben nicht zu
den Volksaufständen über die manche
öffentlich gesprochen haben
wir haben im vergangenen Jahr im Sommer
die Befürchtung gehabt dass viele
Betriebe
in die Pleite gehen würden ist ja nicht
so dass wenn ein Betrieb eine Bäckerei
zum Beispiel keine Brötchen mehr
verkauft dass sie einfach nur Urlaub
machen
sondern die kommen in wirtschaftlich
schwierige
Situationen wir haben nicht massenhaft
in Deutschland Existenzen fordern
wirtschaftliche Strukturen sind eben
nicht weggebrochen weil wir gehandelt
haben wir haben unsere wirtschaftliche
Stärke genutzt
und haben einen Abwehrschirm mit bis zu
200 Milliarden Euro aufgestellt aus dem
wir jetzt die Strom und die
gaspreisbremse finanzieren um die
ruinösen Preis-
fraglos bleibt ein höheres Preisniveau
das ist ja auch gut so soll ja Energie
und Gas eingespart werden aber sie sind
eben nicht mehr ruinös wir haben unsere
wirtschaftliche Stärke genutzt um
Existenzen um Familien um
wirtschaftliche Strukturen zu
verteidigen das kostet viel Geld dass
wir uns an den Kapitalmärkten leihen
müssen ich bin aber zutiefst davon
überzeugt dass dieser Weg richtig ist
denn wir müssen in einem Krisenjahr die
wirtschaftlichen Strukturen erhalten die
wir noch in den Jahren und Jahrzehnten
danach brauchen um in unserem Land
voranzukommen während einer Krise die
wirtschaftliche Kraft des Staates zu
nutzen liebe Freundinnen und Freunde ist
kein Fehler sondern ein Gebot der
Verantwortung während der Krise den
Staat zu nutzen das tun wir der Fehler
entsteht aber dann wenn man nicht den
Ausstieg aus der Krisenpolitik findet
und deshalb müssen wir heute bereits
darüber nachdenken wann und wie
baldmöglichst der Staat die
Krisenpolitik auf Schulden beendet damit
wir nicht die Staatsfinanzen nachhaltig
ruinieren sondern wieder neue Resilienz
neue wirtschaftliche Stärke aufbauen da
ist die Aufgabe
und das tun wir
und letztlich
letztlich ist das auch eine Zeitenwende
die von uns in dieser Hinsicht gefordert
wird nicht nur in sicherheitspolitischer
Hinsicht die Inflation geht an Stück
zurück
wie es scheint Prognosen sind sehr
unsicher immer wieder gab es in den
letzten Monaten ja auch Korrekturen aber
jetzt gegenwärtig gehen wir die
Notenbank und auch die Regierungen ja
davon aus dass wir im Jahr 2024 wieder
eine Zwei vor dem Komma sehen
und wir haben auch eine schwere
Rezession eine tiefe wirtschaftliche
Abkühlung in unserem Land jetzt nicht
gesehen das konnte abgewendet werden
was mich aber liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde besorgt ist auch wenn die
deutsche Wirtschaft jetzt nicht so stark
abtaucht
so richtig aus dem Quark kommen wir auch
nicht wenn man sich anschaut
OECD-Vergleich G20 Vergleich die 27
Mitgliedsländer der Europäischen Union
wir tauchen nicht so stark ab aber so
richtig aus den Startlöchern wieder raus
nach Pandemie und dieser Energie-
es kann niemanden überraschen nicht nur
die Bundeswehr ist vernachlässigt worden
sondern während des vergangenen
Jahrzehnts vor der Pandemie wurde in
Wahrheit doch auch unsere
wirtschaftliche Struktur vernachlässigt
worden sprechen das doch bitte offen
einmal aus die cdu/csu geführte
Bundesregierung hat sich in
ursozialdemokratischer Manier darauf
verlassen dass sich die wirtschaftliche
Stärke die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres
Landes gewissermaßen automatisch
einstellt
cdu/cs und SPD haben sich in der Frage
doch gar nicht unterschieden dass sie
sich darauf konzentriert haben den
einmal erreichten Wohlstand nur zu
verteilen und aus dem Grund ist unser
Land heute viel weniger wettbewerbsfähig
und viel weniger dynamisch als andere
Länder deshalb brauchen wir nicht nur
eine Zeitenwende in der
Sicherheitspolitik wir brauchen auch
Wirtschaftspolitik du Kraft nicht nur
verteilen du musst auch die Frage danach
Stellen wo es herkommen soll sonst
gelingt das nicht
ist aber eine Lernaufgabe
das darf man nicht auf die leichte
Schulter nehmen ist eine Lernaufgabe
nach über einem Jahrzehnt muss ja nur
heute schauen und in den letzten Tagen
was gefordert wird die einen die Grünen
heute kommen später noch mal drauf
zurück sagen ja also wir brauchen jetzt
die Kindergrundsicherung 12 Milliarden
Euro gleich noch einen Satz so dann
heute morgen aus der cdu/csu Milliarden
Zuschüsse für die sozialen
Sicherungssysteme die Pflege ab 10
Milliarden für die Pflege werden
gefordert Herr Pistorius unser neuer
Verteidigungsminister 10 Milliarden Euro
für die Bundeswehr und wir verstehen Sie
mich jetzt nicht das ist alles begründet
und sinnvoll und würde auch gerne tun
und dann wird immer gesagt ja man muss
das Geld geben wenn ich persönlich
genauso wichtig wäre es ja nicht mein
Geld ich bin ja nur der
Vermögensverwalter der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger
aber verstehen Sie worauf ich hinaus
will alles mögliche wird gefordert da
eine soziale Milliarde fordert die
cdu/csu dort eine soziale Milliarde
fordern die Grünen dort eine
militärmilliarde fordert die SPD dort
Anstrengungen für den Klimaschutz die
Milliarden kosten fordert Jena alle
fordern nur Geld und soziale und
ökologische und sicherheitspolitische
Vorhaben sind gewiss sinnvoll und von
mir auch gewünscht wir müssen unserem
Land aber wieder eines verinnerlichen
alle soziale ökologische alle auch
Sicherheitspolitik in unserem Land hat
eine Voraussetzung ein stabiles
wirtschaftliches Fundament Wirtschaft
ist nicht alles aber ohne eine stabile
Wirtschaft ist alles andere nur ein
unerfüllbarer Traum ohne Aussicht auf
Realisierung und deshalb müssen wir erst
die Voraussetzungen in der Wirtschaft
schaffen bevor wir danach soziale
ökologische und militärische Ausgaben
beschließen können das wird nicht anders
gehen
da wird man wird man dann immer so ein
wenig als Spielverderber wenn man wenn
man darauf hinweist aber diesbezüglich
müssen wir uns eben mit Realitäten
anfreunden beim Finanzminister ist ja
gewissermaßen der Amtseid der Beginn der
Fastenzeit muss man andere zum Verzicht
noch zusätzlich aufrufen wir haben es
aber in der Hand ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass wir in der Lage sind
unser wirtschaftliches Fundament zu
stärken
dass wir in der Lage sind unsere
sozialen ökologischen oder auch unsere
sicherheitspolitischen Ziele dass wir
Sie erreichen können wenn wir die
richtigen Schritte gehen und ich will
einige wenige Maßnahmen Martin du warst
ja so liebenswürdig auch selbst ein paar
zu erwähnen einige einige Maßnahmen nur
aus meiner Sicht auch noch kurz
hervorheben
erste Maßnahme
wir müssen zurück zur Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes
im Jahr 2021
aber ich als Finanzminister den
Jahresabschluss gemacht vier Milliarden
Euro haben wir da gezahlt für Zinsen für
die Schulden der Vergangenheit in diesem
Jahr 2023 zahlen wir es zwei Jahre jetzt
her zahlen wir voraussichtlich 40
Milliarden Euro für die Schulden der
Vergangenheit anzüns 40 Milliarden Euro
eine Verzehnfachung 36 Milliarden Euro
mehr als noch vor zwei Jahren stellen
sich das bitte mal vor 36 Milliarden
Euro die wir überweisen an die
Finanzmärkte 36 Milliarden Euro die
nicht zur Verfügung stehen für
Investitionen in Digitalisierung in
Schulen in Infrastrukturen nicht zur
Verfügung stehen für Steuerentlastung
sondern die wir ausschließlich aufwenden
müssen um die Schulden um die Politik
der Vergangenheit zu finanzieren heute
am Flughafen hier in als ich gelandet
bin hat mich ein älterer Polizeibeamter
angesprochen der sagte mir Herr Lindner
halten sie aber kurz bei den Schulden
denn wir können doch auch den Kindern
nicht nur Kredite hinterlassen die die
bedienen müssen der Mann hat recht
soziale Politik bedeutet eben auch keine
Schuldenberge zu vererben
und da da juckt Ricarda lang heute und
sagt ja wenn jemandem die Schuldenbremse
sehr sehr sehr sehr wichtig sei so hat
sie es gesagt sehr sehr sehr sehr
wichtig sei dann müsste man eben dieses
und jenes dann muss der Lindner eben
woanders Geld her besorgen die
Einleitung für die Steuererhöhungen wenn
einem sehr sehr die Schuldenbremse
wichtig ist ja Lindner dann hol das Geld
doch woanders her da ist meine Antwort
ja Ricarda wie wäre es denn mal mit dem
auskommen was der Staat angeht zur
Verfügung hat das wäre ja auch einmal
eine Option denn wir haben in
Deutschland bereits sehr hohe Steuern
und Abgaben nie Idee könnte ja sein dass
einmal der Appetit der Politik für Geld
ausgeben nicht größer ist als die
Fähigkeit der Menschen das Geld zu
verdienen könnt ja auch ein Konzept sein
Nachhaltigkeit
ja auf das nachhaltige Konzept von
Christian Lindner kommen wir gleich noch
mal zu sprechen Herr Decker schauen wir
aber erstmal auf die FDP in Bayern wie
gesagt da steht eine Landtagswahl an die
FDP hat die letzten fünf Landtagswahlen
verloren und in Bayern sieht es mit 3,7
Prozent so die letzten Umfragewerte auch
nicht rosig aus für die FDP
ja da Tod
der weitere Verlust einer
Parlamentsbeteiligung 5,1 Prozent also
hier bei der letzten Landtagswahl in
Bayern ist sie auch in der schwierigen
Situation weil sie dort von der CSU als
Koalitionspartner nicht benötigt wird
die CSU wollen mit den Freien Wählern
weiter regieren und
von der Bundesebene aus gibt es
Gegenwind keinen Rückenwind sondern
sogar Gegenwind ich glaube in Bayern
macht sich die Partei wahrscheinlich
auch gar keine großen Hoffnungen
entscheidender ist dann die am selben
Tag stattfindende
Landtagswahl in Hessen wenn es dort
schief geht und man auch dort aus dem
Landesparlament herausfliegt wird es
sicherlich ernste Diskussionen geben in
der Partei dann sieht es schlecht aus
für die Partei an sich ist sie steckte
sowieso in einem Dilemma also entweder
sie regiert ich erstmal artig mit heißt
macht auch Schulden dann vergrault die
FDP ihr Kernklientel oder sie spielt
Oppositionen in der Regierung das ist
auch das was wir auch gerade erleben
auch das vergrault Wähler also
eigentlichen Dilemma haben sie ein
Rezept um daraus zu kommen also man muss
ja vielleicht noch mal erinnern diese
Koalition kam mir auch für die FDP
völlig
überraschend jetzt hat sich aber durch
die neuen Herausforderungen insbesondere
durch den Ukraine Krieg aber auch
dadurch dass das Thema Klimaschutz eben
massiv auf die politische Agenda
gebracht worden ist z.B auch durch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat sich die
ganze politische Agenda in einer Weise
verändert die völlig gegen die
inhaltlichen und ideologischen
Grundpositionen der FDP steht also wir
brauchen doch jetzt den Staat der wieder
mehr investiert der stärker in das
Marktgeschehen ein der sich vielleicht
auch stärker verschulden muss und das
alles widerspricht marktwirtschaftlichen
Grundpositionen wie sie die
FDP verfischt und insoweit war es am
Anfang schon so sie hatte den weitesten
Weg in diese Koalition und jetzt sind
eigentlich diese Unterschiede innerhalb
der Koalition auch immer stärker
aufgebrochen so dass sie auch nach außen
hin als streitkoalition wahrgenommen
wird und
abgestraft dafür wird aber am stärksten
die FDP jetzt haben sie es gesagt das
sind besondere Zeiten es sind
Krisenzeiten die erfordern Investitionen
in allen nicht nur beim Klima aber auch
wir haben die Energiekrise gehabt wir
haben jetzt die Bundeswehr die
ertüchtigt wird also es gibt Sondertopf
nach Sondertopf Frage ist findet man da
nicht auch noch Reserven in sondertöpfen
um vielleicht die Schuldenbremse
einhalten zu können und trotzdem wie hat
er gesagt den Appetit fürs Geld ausgeben
irgendwie befriedigen ja er hat denke
ich auf einen Punkt hingewiesen
nämlich die gestiegenen Zinsen also es
ist jetzt für den Start natürlich auch
sehr viel teurer sich zu verschulden als
das früher der Fall gewesen ist insoweit
müsste man eigentlich mal die Weisheit
der Schuldenbremse
nachträglich in Frage stellen also man
hätte vieles von diesen Investitionen ja
in der Vergangenheit machen können weil
man sich billiger hätte Verschulden
können dagegen stand aber die
Schuldenbremse jetzt hat die FDP ein
weiteres Problem
diese Sondervermögen die werden auch von
der eigenen Wählerschaft natürlich
durchaus als Schulden betrachtet und
wenn man dann gleichzeitig sagt wir
halten die Schuldenbremse einhäuft aber
diese Sondervermögen an und wenn die
nicht aufgebraucht werden werden sie
dann umgebucht wie bei Corona wogegen ja
die Union auch vor dem
Verfassungsgericht geklagt hat dann wird
das auch von der eigenen Wählerschaft
als Trickserei empfunden und ist eben
schwer vermittelbar
schwer vermittelbar weil ihr letzter
Satz jetzt haben wir in der wir erleben
eben auch jetzt noch mal nach der
verlorenen Berlin-Wahl dass die FDP auch
ankündigt sich auch in der Ampel im Bund
stärker abgrenzen zu wollen besser
profilieren zu wollen und wir sehen dass
es da unterschiedliche Strömungen gibt
in auch innerhalb der FDP also wir haben
einen Wolfgang Kubicki der da ein etwas
härteren Ton
anschlägt und ein Christian Lindner der
doch ein bisschen mäßigen da Auftritt
also wie sind die Unterschied wie einig
ist sich die FDP auch in dem Kurs den
sie vielleicht jetzt in den nächsten
Wochen einschlagen möchte innerhalb
dieser Koalition im Bund bei den Grünen
hat man ja früher immer vom Gegensatz
zwischen Fundamentalisten und real,-
also die Fundamentalisten sind und
diejenigen die die reine leere vertreten
die im Zweifel dann auch lieber in der
Opposition bleiben wollen statt
politische Verantwortung zu übernehmen
und ich glaube das ist doch so ein
bisschen das Problem jetzt in der FDP
das ist
dort eben Teile gibt in der Partei die
noch nicht wirklich in der Regierung
angekommen sind also wenn sie sich etwa
jetzt im Bereich der Außenpolitik die
verteidigungspolitische Sprecherin
Agnes Marie Agnes stark Zimmermann
anhören das kommt einem vor wie eine
Oppositionspolitikerin in der eigenen
Regierung es gibt aber dann einen
anderen Teil in der Partei da gehören
auch jüngere Leute dazu wie Konstantin
coole
Vogel
die er argumentieren dass man auch das
gemeinsam Erreichte in dieser Koalition
stärker herausstellt und damit eben auch
diesen Eindruck dass man sich da
permanent mit vor allem mit den Grünen
streitet
danach nach außen etwas
abschwächt und diese Frage ist in der
FDP nicht wirklich geklärt ja und die
Aufgabe des Vorsitzenden ist natürlich
immer irgendwo die das ausserieren was
dann aber
vielleicht auch als lavieren empfunden
wird Rebecca vielen Dank für den Moment
wir schauen weiter zur nächsten Partei
das ist die Partei Die Linke die hält
ihren politischen Aschermittwoch in
Passau ab in Bayern laut letzten
Umfragen auch eher irrelevant liegt bei
1,6 in den Umfragen und wir hören die
Parteivorsitzende die
co-parteivorsitzende Janine Wissler die
die Rede zum politischen Aschermittwoch
der Partei DIE LINKE hält
der Krieg in der Ukraine ist furchtbar
und wir leben furchtbare Kriege im Jemen
in Syrien
und nun die Außenministerin berborg
spricht ja mal gerne von einer
wertebasierten und feministischen
Außenpolitik
und gleichzeitig liefert Deutschland
Waffen nach Saudi Arabien
nach Saudi-Arabien wo Frauen brutal
unterdrückt werden wo Menschenrechte mit
Füßen getreten werden kajoggi brutal
ermordet wurde und Saudi-Arabien führt
einen verbrecherischen Krieg gegen den
Jemen und Saudi-Arabien führt diesen
Krieg auch mit deutschen Waffen und da
frage ich euch was zum Teufel hat es
denn mit feministischer Außenpolitik zu
tun Waffen an ein Land wie Saudi Arabien
zu liefern damit sich die deutsche
Rüstungsindustrie eine goldene Nase
verdient das liebe Genossen und Genossen
ist Heuchelei das ist verlogen von
feministische Außenpolitik zu sprechen
und Waffen das Saudi Arabien zu liefern
und was hat das denn mit Werte basierte
Außenpolitik zu tun wenn die
Bundesregierung Waffen in die Türkei an
Erdogan liefert ausgerechnet an Erdogan
der nur kurz nach dem schweren nach dem
verheerenden Erdbeben mit 10.000 Toten
der nur kurz nach diesem Erdbeben wieder
syrisch kurdische Gebiete bombardiert
hat was hört man denn da von der
Bundesregierung deutsche Panzer sind in
afrin und man hört von dieser deutschen
Bundesregierung gar nicht keine klaren
Worte gegen diese Angriffe keine klaren
Worte gegen das Verbot unserer
Schwesterpartei der HDP keine klaren
Worte dagegen dass die ganze Opposition
da eingeknastet und unterdrückt wird und
auch das erwarten wir sonst immer von
Wärter orientierte Außenpolitik
überhaupt nicht reden
und jetzt fordert der neue
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius manchmal
denkt man pistolius wäre langsam
treffender jetzt fordert er noch mehr
Geld für die Rüstung mehr als nur zwei
Prozent Ziel noch ein höheres
Sondervermögen Rheinmetall freuts die
profitieren davon und von den
Beschaffungswesen der Bundeswehr oder
man könnte auch sagen dass Konzern
bereicherungswesen der Bundeswehr und
dieses Geld das wird doch dringend
gebraucht für andere für andere zentrale
Fragen nämlich für den Klimaschutz für
Soziales für Bildung dafür brauchen wir
doch dringend Geld statt immer mehr in
die Aufrüstung zu stecken und wisst ihr
was man würde sich doch wünschen das
Krankenhäuser und Pflegekräfte eine
ähnlich hörbaren Lautsprecher in der
Ampel hätten wie die Rüstungsindustrie
die haben nämlich keinen
und dann hat
[Musik]
die Arm 53 Euro mehr die viele Menschen
direkt weiter überweisen an ihren
Stromversorger
die Kinder Grundsicherung ist verschoben
auf 2024 ja warum haben wir es eilig
E-Mail das sind arme Kinder Kinder haben
nur eine Kindheit und das zeigt doch die
ganze Prioritätensetzung der Ampel man
braucht drei Monate um 100 Milliarden
für die Bundeswehr zu mobilisieren aber
man braucht drei Jahre um die Kinder
Grundsicherung auf dem Weg zu bringen
und noch gibt es nicht man Gesetzentwurf
und das ist doch eine Schande eine
Bundesregierung die solche Prioritäten
selbst liebe Genossen
[Applaus]
und dann stellt sich der Finanzminister
Linda hin und sagt
in dieser Krise werden wir alle ärmer
nein nein wir werden nicht alle ärmer es
gibt Leute denen geht es verdammt gut in
dieser Krise
die fahren sagenhafte übergewinne ein
Mineralölkonzerne Energiekonzerne
Rüstungsindustrie geht super und deshalb
sagen wir wir brauchen doch endlich eine
übergewinnsteuer sowie in Spanien wir
haben eine übergewinnsteuer eingeführten
was haben sie gemacht kostenfreien ÖPNV
für alle das ist doch eine Maßnahme die
wir brauchen
meine Mutter mal an die Ursache rangehen
und das macht die Ampel ja nicht die
Ampel bekämpft immer nur Symptome und
geht nicht an die Ursache wir brauchen
nicht einfach eine Bremse der
energiepreisbremse nein wir brauchen
eine wirksame Kontrolle der Preise bei
Energie wir brauchen dann Vorgehen gegen
Spekulation und Bereicherung und das ist
natürlich ein Bundeskanzler Scholz der
war ja schon als Finanzminister hat er
ja schon reich und Konzerne geschont
seine schützende Hand aber die Warburg
Bank gehalten und über die ganzen commex
Geschäfte also und ich meine das sind
Bundeskanzler der im Wahlkampf sein
Wählerinnen und WLAN versprochen hat mit
mir gibt es Respekt ja wo ist denn
dieser Respekt Respekt würde es doch
Gebieten dass das Thema Kinderarmut und
Altersarmut und die zutiefst ungerechte
Verteilung von Reichtum dass das mal
ganz oben beim Bundeskanzler liegen
würde und man das nicht einfach
verschiebt und dass man sich nicht mit
der zutiefst ungerechten Verteilung von
Reichtum in diesem Land einfach ab
findet indem man Steuer einfach mal
total ausschließen Koalitionsvertrag
ja und Liebe Genossin genossen wer sich
von grüner Regierungsbeteiligung einen
effektiven Klimaschutz versprochen hat
der wurde enttäuscht
im Jahr 2023 wo sich die Klimakrise
zuspitzt überhaupt nicht klar als ob man
die Klimaerwärmung noch unter zwei Grad
begrenzen kann in einer Zeit wo ja auch
direkt die Folgen das Klimawandels nicht
einfach so ein fernes Horrorszenario
sondern wir merken es doch die Hitze
Toten in den Sommer die sinkenden Pegel
in den Flüssen ich habe gehört letztes
Jahr konnte ja auch kein Schiff fahren
die Waldbrände die Überschwemmungen die
Hungersnöte durch dürren in einer
solchen Zeit wird im Jahr 2023 in
Deutschland ein Dorf abgebaggert
Lutzerath
es wird abgebaggert um die darunter
liegende Kohle zu gewinnen
und es wurde nicht nur ein Dorf
abgebaggert sondern auch gleich ein
Windpark mit abgerissen ein Windpark
wird abgerissen und Braunkohle abzubauen
und das ganze wurde verkündet vom grünen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck und der
Grünen
landeswirtschaftsministerin in
Nordrhein-Westfalen seit an seit mit RWE
weil es geht ja auch um die Interessen
von RWE und das wenn ich einmal schön
wenn es um RWE geht da hat man ja gar
kein Problem mit Enteignungen da kann
man mal fruchtbaren Ackerboden da kann
man mal die Bauer da kann man mal die
Anwohner die kann man dann enteignen
wobei ich ja sagen würde was RWE macht
ist sicher nicht gemeinnützig das ist
eher gemein gefährlich das weitere
Abbaggern von Kohle
aber was wir noch sehen ist ob Autobahn
Flughafenausbau oder Kohle immer wenn es
mal ernst wird dann zeigen die Grünen
ein Rückgrat wie Wackelpudding
es ist einfach nicht existent sie sind
nicht bereit sich mit Bereichen mit
herrschenden ja nicht mal mit dem
Koalitionspartner anzulegen und ich
meine jetzt ist es ja so nachdem die CSU
Ewigkeiten fest auf dem Sessel das
Bundesverkehrsministers geklebt hat so
als Anti klimakleber sozusagen
jetzt kommen wir vom Regen in die Traufe
mit wem weil auf andreas Scheuer hier in
Passau gut bekannt folgte ja Herr
Wissing und er Wissing ist ja sowas wie
die personifizierte Blockade der
Verkehrswende er ist derjenige der sich
weigert auch nur ein Tempolimit
einzuführen ich will doch eine weitere
große Gefahr ansprechen und das ist die
Gefahr von rechts dass er starken von
Rechten Kräften überall auf der Welt in
Europa wir haben erlebte rechten Terror
das NSU in Halle in Hanau und spätestens
seit der Razzia bei den reichsbürgern im
letzten Jahr spätestens seitdem ist
vollkommen klar die AFD ist der
parlamentarische Arm das recht teuer ist
muss und deshalb ist eine entscheidende
Aufgabe für uns als Linke den Kampf
gegen Rechtsaußen zu führen und den
alten und den neuen Nazis in den Weg zu
stellen damit sie niemals wieder
durchkommen weil wir aus der Geschichte
gelernt haben
[Applaus]
und Kampf gegen Rechtsaußen bedeutet
auch den alltäglichen den
institutionellen Rassismus zu bekämpfen
und das heißt wir müssen auch rüber
reden über die Stichwortgeber aus der
sogenannten Mitte die Rassismus in
diesem Land führen und da bin ich
natürlich bei Friedrich Merz der von
sozialtourismusphase wenn er Flüchtlinge
aus der Ukraine meint der Kinder mit
Migrationshintergrund als kleine Paschas
bezeichnet und vor dem arabischen von
Pässen waren so vergiftet man das Klima
und wenn Jens Spahn vor toxischer
Männlichkeit warnt dann sollte er sich
mal mit seinem eigenen
parteienvorsitzende beschäftigt das ist
nämlich die personifizierte toxische
Männlichkeit Friedrich Merz der gegen
die vergewaltigt gegen die Strafbarkeit
der Vergewaltigung in der Ehe gefühlt
hat
diese Art gegen geflüchtete zu
polemisieren das ist eine Schande für
eine Partei die sich christlich nennt
und wir sagen klar unsere Solidarität
liegt bei den geflüchteten aus der
Ukraine aber natürlich auch bei allen
anderen Menschen die flüchten vor Bomben
und Krieg
ja Janine Wissler war das Deko
Parteivorsitzende von der Partei DIE
LINKE Atmosphäre war das erinnerte mich
das zumindest eher an einen
Wahlkampfrede hatte jetzt wenig
humorvolle Aspekte war jetzt nicht so
politische Aschermittwoch wir haben sie
das wahrgenommen ja am politischen
Aschermittwoch werden ja Wahlkampf Reden
gehalten
Gegner abarbeiten
an Friedrich Merz ich würde gerne mit
einem anderen Thema einsteigen sie hat
den Kampf gegen rechts außen genannt da
hätte man erwarten können dass sie
vielleicht auch noch mal Bezug nimmt auf
das Manifest für den Frieden von ihrer
Parteikollegen Sarah Wagenknecht wo ja
auch die Kritik lautet dass ich da jetzt
viele Rechte anschließen an dieses
Manifest also ist das wenn man Probleme
einfach nicht erwähnt existieren sie
nicht oder was ist das für eine
Strategie stellt sich die Frage der
Glaubwürdigkeit also sie kann das ja an
lernen aber die Frage ist ob die Linke
das dann selber beherzigt und es gibt ja
in der also in der Politikwissenschaft
gibt es diese Hufeisen Theorie das
sozusagen die extremen Enden sich dann
wieder annähern und Übereinstimmungen
aufweisen und dich sind ja frappant wenn
man sich jetzt die Russlandpolitik
betrachtet und von daher war das ja
völlig naiv zu glauben von den
Unterstützern dieses Manifests dass sich
jetzt direkt extrem davon fernhalten
würden also die
Linke hat ein massives Problem sich eben
dort glaubwürdig abzugrenzen gerade in
dieser Frage ja also nicht nur gegenüber
rechts aber auch gegenüber Abgrenzung
gegenüber Russland und Putin auch das
ist gelingt selbst in dieser Phase nicht
eindeutig woran liegt das ja es gibt ja
manche die sagen also im Grunde ist das
ein faschistisches Regime in Russland
also gerade wichtige Partei die sich
immer als antifaschistisch betrachtet
müsste sich doch rigoros von einem
solchen Regime abgrenzt also wie kann
man überhaupt diese Russland nee
erklären das hat natürlich mit mit der
Sowjetunion zu tun mit der eigenen
Vergangenheit und der Linken ist es
nicht wirklich gelungen dort auch eine
vernünftige glaubwürdige Position zu
entwickeln also die Zerstrittenheit ist
ja größer denn je also wir haben dann
auf der einen Seite
Wagenknecht mit der die Partei ja auch
aus ganz anderen Gründen hadert und auf
der anderen Seite Leute wie Bodo ramolo
die sagen selbstverständlich hat die
Ukraine das Recht sich zu verteidigen
und selbstverständlich müssen wir sie
dort eben auch mit Waffen
unterstützen und das kriegt die Linke
nicht zusammen
er steht vielleicht ein Stück näher bei
Ramelow hat allerdings auch
die Frage nach seiner eigenen
Glaubwürdigkeit
zu beantworten also wenn man ihn mal
daran erinnert an seine Äußerungen zu
einer Wahl nie ich glaube einfach das
kann die Linke nicht glaubwürdig
vermitteln und deshalb ist sie jetzt in
einer Position
wo sie die Menschen wirklich davon
überzeugen möchte dass man jetzt
diplomatische Lösungen einschlagen soll
ich weiß gar nicht ob die Partei das
selber glaubt dass das funktioniert aber
sie macht das wahrscheinlich nur deshalb
um ihr eigenes Gesicht waren zu können
denn ansonsten stünde sie vor dem
totalen Scherbenhaufen der eigenen
Politik noch weitaus stärker als das bei
anderen Parteien bei der SPD auch bei
den Unionsparteien der Fall ist die
natürlich diese Fehler der Vergangenheit
ebenfalls aufarbeiten müssen
Janine Wissler hat das heute noch mal
wiederholt diese Forderungen nach
diplomatischen Verhandlungen im Russland
Ukraine Konflikt würde gern noch mal auf
die Person Sahra Wagenknecht schauen
da wird viel diskutiert Parteiausschluss
ja oder nein man zögert aus guten
Gründen
ich glaube die Linke müsste eine
wagenknecht-partei weniger fürchten als
die AFD und sie hätte dann natürlich
auch das Problem der Abgrenzung zum
Rechtsextremismus deshalb glaube ich
nicht dass sie das machen wird und sie
ist ja auch gescheitert mit einem
Versuch sie hat wollt ihr eine eine
Bewegung Gründen Aufstehen das hat alles
nicht verfangen und aus ihrer eigenen
Sicht ist es vielleicht
rationaler in der Linken zu bleiben denn
sie wird ja
von den Medien das muss man sagen
regelrecht hofiert also im Grunde als
eine Stimme betrachtet die repräsentativ
ist für eine bestimmte Strömung in der
Partei was sie aber überhaupt nicht mehr
ist also eigentlich ist das Tischtuch
zwischen Wagenknecht und ihrer Parteien
längst zerschnitten sich scheut aber den
Schritt diese Partei zu verlassen
herzlichen Dank beim Bäcker für den
Moment und wir schauen zur nächsten
Partei die AFD die feiert ihren
politischen Aschermittwoch in Osterhofen
und genau dort schauen wir jetzt hin
servus grüß euch und habe die Ehre beim
zweitgrößten ausschermittwoch der
Geschichte war der einzigen Partei die
noch klar zu Deutschland steht bei der
Alternative für Deutschland meine Damen
und Herren unser Land zuerst das Thema
und das wird auch Thema bleiben die
ganzen Wahlkampf meine Damen
zuerst möchte ich sagen wir haben heute
wieder ein Urteil bekommen vom Gericht
von Karlsruhe die Karlsruhe Richter
haben den Altparteien Kartell wieder
mehr bestätigt dass sie undemokratisch
sind die AFD hat wieder mal vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht gewonnen meine
Damen und Herren wir sind gekommen um zu
bleiben meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
wir schreiben zehn Jahre zehn Jahre
Erfolgsgeschichte wir sind die
erfolgreichste Partei in den
Nachkriegsgeschichte Deutschlands meine
Damen und Herren und warum sind wir es
weil wir aus Überzeugung machen weil wir
mit Herzen bei der Sache sind weil wir
unser Land leben unsere Heimat lieben
unsere Kulturleben und deswegen stehen
wir dazu um was den schwarzen
skandalpolitikern nicht passt ja wir
waren früher als alle Unionspolitiker
aber uns hat die Union mit Füßen
getreten meine Damen und Herren die
Konservativen wurden mit Füßen getreten
und werden heute noch mit Füßen getreten
von Union meine Damen und Herren
der Name Franz Josef Franz Josef führte
holzkosten heute hier wohlfühlen meine
Damen und Herren da wird sie nicht nur
hier wohlfühlen meine Damen und Franz
Josef Strauß wir unser
Bundesvorsitzender meine Damen denn wir
sind eine deutschlandweite CSU die schon
lange von Nöten war meine Damen und
Herren wenn Schüler ein einziges Mal
sein Wort halten würde
hätte er am ersten ersten 23
zurücktreten müssen
erinnern
2010 war der Umweltminister
da hat er mit grüner Krawatte gesprochen
mit grüner Krawatte unser
Landesvater heutige Landesvater oder
Landesverräter herzbewässerung
hat mit grüner
Krawatte gesprochen wenn die
Kernkraftwerke nicht um 31.12 22
abgeschaltet werden dann tritt er zurück
Schüler steht zu deinen Wort tritt
zurück ich brauche kein Mensch
[Musik]
in der Presse wurde ja ganz klar als
Atoms aus atomausstiegsminister mit
grüner Krawatte debattiert aber grün ist
ja die Zukunft der Farbe selbst Söder
und Weber der stellvertretende
Landesvorsitzender oder wie auch immer
das sein soll bei denen
sprechen dass der Grünen der Partner der
Koalitionspartner der Zukunft sind Franz
Josef Strauß wird sich im Glauben und
drehen meinen Namen und Herren wenn das
Söder oder irgendjemand anders mit den
Grünen ins Bett steigen würde das ist
ein versorgen einer schwarzer Politik
die kein Mensch mehr braucht in diesem
Land meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
aber nicht nur dass er unser schöne
Kernkraft zerstört hat oder sonst
irgendwas anderes zerstört hat wird
vorher bin ja für Ernährung in
Landwirtschaft daheim Deutschen
Bundestag zu den zuständig jeden Tag
schließen 5 landwirtschaftliche Betriebe
in Bayern meine Damen und Herren Bayern
ist ein Landwirtschaftsland und das
Schüler macht's kaputt meine Damen seit
1957 ist die Registrierung aus der CSU
gestaltet meistens Alleinherrschaft und
was ist aus unserem Land geworden
mittlerweile lacht die ganze Welt über
Bayern und nicht mehr die Sonne meine
Damen und Herren bin gespannt wann die
CSU ihr ziehe meine auswechselt
gegenüber ein Halbmond
irgendwann kommt nämlich da vorne nicht
mehr das Sehen sondern kommt der
Halbmond hin der Söder stellt sich auf
ein Marktplatz
und sagt da Islam gehört zu Deutschland
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Söder muss weg ja genau
es ist vorher schon angesprochen
selbst Söder vertritt ja die Meinung im
Iran unten reißen sich die Frauen die
Kopftücher von Kopf die Burka die
Nietzsche
dass man Deutschland die Wörter oder
nicht Job überhaupt kennt die sollte man
in Deutschland gar nicht kennen die
Begriffe aber im Iran werden die Leute
gefeiert
werden die Leute gefeiert die Frauen
gefahren auch zurecht was er sich die
Kopftücher runterreißen weil es Freiheit
ist und in Deutschland wäre es genau
andersrum da ist es tragen einen
Litscher einer Burka oder was sie frei
meine Damen und das ist keine Frage
meine das ist die Unterdrückung der Frau
und es ist extrem rückständig das ist
vor gerichtsgeschichte und das dauert es
in Deutschland nicht geben meine Damen
und Herren
und wenn sie dann die süderbündel
öfters laufen sind als ja heute wieder
die selbstbewahrung in Passau unten zur
österreichischen Grenzen
tut mir leid vielleicht können wir das
ausgliedern
ganz ehrlich die CSU braucht kein Mensch
mehr
stefan proczka war dass der
Landesvorsitzende der AFD in Bayern der
sich an Markus Söder CDU CSU-Chef
abgearbeitet hat
Herr Decker die AFD liegt aktuell bei
9,7 Prozent Umfragen in Bayern die
letzte Landtagswahl 2018 da hat die AFD
11,2% geholt liegt das jetzt so ein
bisschen unter dem letzten
Landtagswahlergebnis wir wissen nicht ob
das so bleibt sondern ein bisschen hin
aber gibt es Gründe dafür oder könnte es
Gründe geben ja es ist Söder hat hier
seine
Position korrigiert also er hat das
haben wir heute auch in der Rede gehört
Dritter eigentlich relativ moderat auf
und hat sich strikt von der AFD
abgegrenzt und auf der anderen Seite
haben wir in Bayern aber auch die Freien
Wähler die so bisschen auch mit diesem
Thema
einfacher spricht sowieso eine deftigere
Sprache in diesem Fehler Reservoir
wildern und damit aus meiner Sicht die
AFD des afd-potenzial in Bayern auch
begrenzen denn das ist gegen den
Bundestrend also in der Bundestagswahl
lag die AFD ja bei zehn Prozent sie ist
aber jetzt in den Umfragen
zwischenzeitlich wieder gestiegen und
das ist ja auch nicht verwunderlich weil
jetzt diese krisenhaften Entwicklungen
auch die Zunahme eben auch von
Fluchtbewegungen nicht nur aus der
Ukraine sondern wir haben das ja auch
aus den Nahen Osten und Afrika das
spielt der Partei natürlich in die Hände
also die AFD die Partei die immer von
den Krisen profitiert in der wählergrund
wobei muss man festhalten der Wut Winter
den sie prognostiziert hat den sie
sozusagen auch erhofft hatte dass er
kommen würde der ist nicht wirklich
eingetreten lassen uns noch einmal über
einen erweiteres Thema sprechen was
heute ganz tagesaktuell mit der AFD zu
tun hat da gab es heute eine
Entscheidung vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe
und das hat zu tun mit einer Parteien an
Stiftung der erasmus-stiftung also
Parteien haben ja diverse Stiftungen die
AFD eben auch diese Stiftung hat bislang
kein Geld bekommen und die AFD sah sich
da benachteiligt und hat vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht geklagt was
genau sind die Hintergründe noch mal und
die Entscheidung nächste Mal hat sie
Recht bekommen also in diesem Anspruch
und
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat das in
einem früheren Urteil schon festgestellt
wenn eine Partei fest etabliert ist und
dann nimmt man als Maßgabe immer zwei
Legislaturperioden das ist aber jetzt
bei der AFD der Fall dann hat sie eben
Anspruch auch hier staatliche Mittel zu
bekommen für eine Parteien nach Stiftung
in diesem Urteil gibt es aber einen
Finger zeigen bisher sind diese Mittel
verteilt worden
vom Haushalts Ausschuss das heißt die
ganze stiftungsfinanzierung hatte
überhaupt keine gesetzliche Grundlage
und das Verfassungsgericht hat jetzt
gesagt es braucht ein Stiftungsgesetz
und in diesem Stiftungsgesetz kann man
natürlich dann auch die Kriterien für
die Vergabe der staatlichen Mittel auch
regeln das ist die Sache des
Gesetzgebers und da geht es dann zum
Beispiel darum ob man auch zur Bedingung
macht dass eine Partei nach Stiftung
bedingungslos Eintritt für die
freiheitliche demokratische Grundordnung
also wir hätten hier eine ähnliche
Möglichkeit wie bei der Parteien
Finanzierung wo Parteien eben die nicht
auf dem Boden des Grundgesetzes stehen
auch aus der staatlichen Finanzierung
ausgeschlossen werden können also der
Gesetzgeber ist jetzt gefordert ein
solches Stiftungsgesetz zu erlassen
herzlichen Dank für ihre Analyse heute
den ganzen Vormittag über haben wir den
politischen Aschermittwoch der
unterschiedlichen Parteien analysiert
herzlichen Dank dass sie da waren bei
uns danke ja jetzt schauen wir noch mal
auf dieses Thema was wir gerade
besprochen haben also die Arbeit
parteiener Stiftungen die wird in
Deutschland gegenwärtig mit rund 660
Millionen Euro jährliche gefördert und
die erasmus-stiftung die parte i die
afd-partei nahe Stiftung